on this
night when we write this all
happens prepare to be scared
and disturbed
[Laughter]
happy halloween
hey everybody trick or treating trick or
treat
happy halloween i'm only gonna i only
wanted to like reveal the costume
without my glasses however unfortunately
i will have to be nerdy vampire amy from
fright night because i can't see a
[ __ ] thing without my glasses on
everything just looks super super blurry
which is very sad
yeah the uh so today is going to be what
halloween murders that was uh
overwhelmingly what won the poll
i was kind of like i don't you know i'm
not like i was i was kind of hoping it'd
be something more fun because it's like
i kind of feel bad like
like having like a fun halloween show
and it's like all [ __ ]
murders and [ __ ] but what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
i feel like this is kind of the only
halloween [ __ ] that we haven't done yet
like the only halloween
topic so uh you know here we go so uh
yeah like i said
i spent so [ __ ] i spent all day on
this [ __ ] costume and it's like
well what what happened was that i had
um i had this mask that i bought and it
had like this really cool
like latex like mount like vampire mouth
all these [ __ ] fangs and stuff and i
was like whoo i'll just cut that out and
i put it on with spirit gum and stuff
and it worked kind of but then like i um
i kind of couldn't get the the edges
they were like too
bumpy and rough and like i couldn't get
him to like stick down and i couldn't
get to like match my face and then i was
like [ __ ] it so i just like pulled it
all off and i was like [ __ ] i'm just
gonna do it with makeup so i didn't do
it like really quick
so hopefully it doesn't look too bad on
camera it looks like it looks kind of
shitty in my mirror but it's like
i looked at it on camera i'm like it
doesn't look too bad it's kind of like
you know yeah
i like this wig though i gotta say but
let me ask you something darling
is he [ __ ] you is he [ __ ] here
he's in practice it is michael koenig he
said all day you guys
no i have it's a lie well for the last
couple of minutes
is he [ __ ] you oh so he's fine that's
pretty good actually it's pretty good
what i was gonna do like i said oh my
goodness somebody said i can't see hold
on thank you victor
[Laughter]
do you say victor says y'all are awesome
thanks garcia what i was gonna do
i was actually even gonna do like a
vampire bite on my shoulder but i didn't
have time because i was like ooh i'm
like all attention to detail what i was
gonna do if i could see anything
was i was gonna like have my back turned
like when the show started and then i
was gonna go
you promised you wouldn't let him get me
and then i was going to turn around and
go blah
but you know so i just did it just
yes it's my favorite day of the year
sorry i'm ruining the costume
but like can you guys see like i have i
even have like contact lenses and
everything they're like
red and yellow so that's also
contributing to me not really being
able to see so sorry i'm putting like
the glasses on now
so now i can see everybody saying i
should glue some glued some of them
young curls to my chest
i don't think i don't think he had chest
hair did he
i wasn't really paying attention to
whether he had chest hair or not
i couldn't quite get this wig crazy
enough because
michael caine's real hair at that point
in his career with some scruffy [ __ ] man
it was going all over it
about three times as thick as it should
have been but i do have
i do have all the wires right yeah he
got all the look he even got elected
electrodes and [ __ ]
yeah what happened to your severed hand
did it fall off right here oh is it my
crotch
it's holding it you know i'm talking
about it's holding it
hold it yeah okay that's fair enough
[Laughter]
i like how you're all like [ __ ]
unzipped
that's how you had it that's how i had
it it comes up out of the chair
oh if we'd have thought about it we
could have like put look where's um
where's the [ __ ] pumpkin
i carved [ __ ] i thought i thought you
put it back there
oh there it is you can hardly see yeah
it's a little ghosty
i was gonna do last year i did um i did
two pumpkins didn't i
and i freestyled them i was just like
[ __ ] i'm just gonna like carve a face
i'm gonna draw that [ __ ] on there
because that's how i roll
um this year i kind of like uh left
everything in the last minute like
what else is new and um so i just had to
like use one of the stencily things and
i was just like what's the easiest one
okay ghosty i'm just putting that on
there
because you know i had to do it like
this morning but yeah so
i have almost jenny's hair color a
little less orangey this you know what's
weird this wig
is actually very close to my natural
hair color
before i started dyeing it black it's
probably gray now i'm not really sure
i've been dying it black for so long i'm
like almost afraid to let it grow out
but yeah who is with baby yoda there is
um frankenstein's monster is back there
like next to baby oda is there somebody
on the other side of baby yoda did i put
somebody on the other side of baby yoda
frankenstein
well no i know but on the other side no
just another pumpkin
oh okay so oh yeah there's a little
ceramic pumpkin back there that my mom
made a long time ago but i did put like
frankenstein's monster i liked
i enjoyed that frankenstein's monster
was so much smaller than baby yoda
you know what i mean yeah because baby
odo's like godzilla yeah
dljm sent us 20 pounds thanks bro thank
you thank you thank you
yeah that's dan tila's in the house
she's seen wild or something
your hair probably yeah she says i look
good with that hair you know
i told him well i don't know what wig
you ended up getting but when you were
like looking at the wigs
i was like you need to get a willy wonka
yeah it's really wonky
like from the original that's what i
thought yeah i [ __ ] pulled it out and
[ __ ] cut some [ __ ] off of it because
that was the one that looked the most
like michael caine's hair
in the hand yeah you know yeah it was
willy wonka's hair what was that can you
have like two guys having that
particular terrible hair
yeah at least willy wonka like had the
excuse of being like all right this was
a lot
thinner a lot thinner it was like there
was like a hard part like on one side
and then it was just like [ __ ]
who thought that was a good idea i don't
really know i liked it on willy wonka
but that was about it
michael shaffer said you look so much
younger with hair
mate yeah well i have hair
you know what i mean yeah i already have
hair why would anybody be talking about
me
look like your hair is looking red it is
yeah but like i said this is like my
natural hair color
i just like i kind of like this wig
though it's much longer than it looks i
was trying to like foof it because
in the movie it was like kind of teased
you know what i mean but this is like
this is pretty close actually i couldn't
actually grow out hair a haircut like
this it would look like [ __ ] on me
my hair's straight and it's [ __ ] dark
and it's [ __ ] thin
although i just thought of something if
you had hair like that and then you grew
facial hair no one would recognize no
they never recognized you just
be completely like incognito at my age
you have to [ __ ] get what's called
a hair system a hair it's a
technological system
it's like kind of like some of these
girls that get these bolt-on titties
they call them bolt-ons
you got to have like a system a hair
system also known as a wig
well yeah yeah everything sounds better
because it's just the hair system
yeah did you guys see that we also have
uh
halloween appropriate cups yeah for our
mine's trick-or-treat you guys gonna
have to be drinking for this one
and as soon as it gets dark if the
show's still going on i gotta answer the
door
hopefully we don't have there'd be
trick-or-treaters hopefully we won't
have that many so we can eat the rest of
the candy that's true
because we got the good [ __ ] and you got
the shining cup
yeah i got that's a pretty cool like
show it to the camera show it through
the game
because it would just get lost and get
lost in my
yeah but the twins are on the other side
yeah i got them at spirit halloween the
other day
man tila says if tom put on a mustache
he could do mark twain
[Laughter]
yeah if you like sprayed it with a
little white i could see that because i
always feel like mark twain i mean you
know he was young at some point but it's
like i always feel like um
that very famous picture of this crazy
like [ __ ] white einstein hair
you can't see it in this lighting but my
hair my eyes are also [ __ ] red
i got red eyeshadow because you know
[ __ ]
at this point in the movie kane just
looked like a [ __ ] maniac
they had red they had they had his eye
sockets read it out [ __ ] red shadow
i think it was [ __ ] half something i
can kind of see it yeah but you can't
see it in this light
yeah but like i said the dark is
actually good because it
you know it kind of makes the costumes
look better and by that time the hand
was pretty rotten but it was still
[ __ ] running around
you know what's weird you would think in
this halloween
loving country that i would be able to
find
a fake hand that was like kind of like
decayed like a zombie hand
like just the hand but every single
[ __ ] hand that looked like that
it had like part of the forearm i'm like
i don't want the whole [ __ ] forearm i
just
want the hand why was that so difficult
to find so i finally just had to get
that plane i'm like here this is like
the only one i could find and it was
like [ __ ] six dollars
so you know yeah it might at some point
during the show it might come over and
like kill me
either it was the psychic forces it was
just psychic will
power [ __ ] oliver stone made the
movie you know he was with
[ __ ] around with john millies at that
time they were writing the script for
[ __ ] conan
which is all about nichia and will but
in this case this was a
that [ __ ] toxic toxic masculinity and
[ __ ] psychic abilities
or delusion one of the two you couldn't
thank you logan holy [ __ ]
crap damn thanks what did he say he says
happy halloween y'all
in beijing thank you very much amazing
costumes guys
thank you very much i'm glad that the
costumes came out cool because
he didn't see mine and i didn't see his
like i had we saw all the components of
it but we just like i didn't even like
put it together until like a couple
hours ago and i was like
okay it looks better if i keep my mouth
shut though because then i said
[Music]
all right see much better
i'm i'm ready for the show tonight oh
i'll bet you i'm ready for this [ __ ] i
got to snap out of it i got to snap out
of it and get more comfortable because
now i'm [ __ ]
this this this costume is [ __ ]
restricting my personality
you think it would be enhancing it no
let me drink some let me just
let you drink some let me drink some
okay let me [ __ ] arrange my beautiful
hair
there we go you need to start wearing
that all the time just
randomly said is he [ __ ] you let me
ask you something my darling my dear is
he [ __ ] you
that's hilarious the more you started
yelling the hands going
crawling towards her i know that's what
i mean it might come over there and go
we'll have like a the hand fright night
crossover yeah
oh my god my hair is getting stuck in my
[ __ ] mouth makeup
so is there any shout outs or anything
yes many many many shout outs
all right so the first shout out we have
a new patron this week
and they're called out running errands
not like not aaron's
with a d but aaron with like
the name aaron you know what i mean you
got it
i probably overexplained it but yeah so
out running errands is our newest
patron so thank you very much also i
want to thank
scott for a very generous paypal
donation earlier in the week
um so thank you very much for that scott
also want to thank
louie who sends us many many movies and
he sent us
the box of the future trilogy on blu-ray
that's a blu-ray steelbook it's the 35th
anniversary is that steel book
yes it is awesome that's a b i got the
old edition but
i got the old edition but it's like it's
fat that'll actually help me save some
room
this is actually much nicer yeah this is
like the newer one and it has like all
bunch of extra [ __ ] that our old ones do
not have on
they didn't re-edit that one did they oh
i don't know because there was one
re-edit where they just
made it they got rid of the lala
magazine i don't know if that's it or
not
hmm i didn't hear about that yeah they
were complaining about it
someone was complaining about them yeah
that was complaining about some
also want to say this is super cool we
were like all getting ready for the show
and whatnot
and then the doorbell rings this morning
and this lady
from smash cakes brings us a little
thing
of halloween cupcakes courtesy of sophie
yeah they were [ __ ] great too they
had a little booze that you injected in
them on a little drop right there
you squeezed it you put the booze in
there yeah it had looked like broken
glass and blood and [ __ ] on top of it
halloween cupcakes thank you dj maniac i
can't compete with logan but happy
halloween very few of us can it's like
we're not high rollers
but yeah so that so um yeah that was the
red velvet one i wanted to say like the
red velvet one was like really really
good
um because it's like the the cake wasn't
real sweet and then like the frosting
was really sweet which i like but it was
like a good combination
i don't know what kind of booze that was
it was like the red
you squeezed it and it was all like
bloody inside but it had like the sugar
glass on the top which i just i didn't
eat it cause i think thanks but that's
dj maniac yeah tina tell me shut up wait
till you shut up
dude i'm telling you to shut up sit shut
up tom let my ass off i said something
but i remember i don't know what it was
i don't i
didn't see anybody say shut up shut up
mark said tom's the straight richard
simmons
that's a good one i bet if you get drunk
enough will you please get up and start
doing calisthenics
yeah then mark says tom the lead singer
for nickelback
i can't remember what that douche looks
like what does that [ __ ] douche look
like
i don't know but it's just the uh they
all do i ought to do [ __ ] hold on one
sec
i'm looking from here what it looks like
to me is i look like [ __ ] um
robert plant oh my god you do
yeah hey mama said the way you move
yeah that's very funny
oh [ __ ] that's what we should do next
year
we'll dress up as because legendary
zeppelin
or i don't know i was gonna i didn't i
mean taught me the queen
murder yeah
i don't know what the words of that song
are when the levy breaks you got no
place to stay
yeah and then dj maniac said he looks
like kurt cobain if he had lived and not
met courtney love
or got into heroin
very specific set of circumstances there
you're funny oh my god all right so i
did all this so yeah the cupcakes are
like really really good
i've only eaten one of the red velvet
ones um but the other one
one of the other ones was pumpkin spice
right and then i think the other one
might be
salted caramel i'm not real sure it says
on there and
they all had different kind of booze in
there i couldn't tell what kind of booze
was in there but i was just like
whatever i appreciate it tastes like
alcohol that's like good enough for me
um i thought i was going to get oh this
is a this is a
vodka sunrise yeah yeah no it's a
vodka sunset okay because i was going to
say maybe i should have a bloody mary
because it's a hollow that's right that
should ask for
yeah yeah i'll make you my next one
that's all right i'll have that okay
because i got some things angry i got it
yeah i got them i got a lot of zigzag
that's what i thought if you guys have
never had zing zang
[ __ ] bloody mary zang it's a it's a
[ __ ] that's the best
bloody mary mix you can [ __ ] imagine
it's almost like vichy sua
i know i can drink that [ __ ] yeah it's
got a lot of celery seed and a lot of
fun spice in it it's good
i'm into all the celery seed i know some
people don't like that but i'm just like
yeah man
i just just like i like pulpy orange
juice yeah we had this there's this
barley used to go to called the grotto
and uh that's when the first time the
guy tried to give me some zheng zang as
a
for bloody mary mix i was like oh man
that shit's [ __ ] awesome i gave some
of jenny she's like
she was like sold on it yeah i'm like
this needs a big old fat
shrimp around the edges that's what this
is so given
i bought some [ __ ] zing zang
margarita mix it was too sweet i didn't
like it
i didn't like it they're all pretty good
yeah i like a good bloody mary yeah the
zing zang regular bloody mary mix is
[ __ ]
the best yeah that's the one i usually
get
and like i said i bought it like a while
back and had like one bloody mary and
then i forgot it was in the [ __ ]
refrigerator
yeah you know and then i thought oh for
the halloween show i'm like oh obviously
i should have a bloody mary i don't have
no [ __ ]
celery to put in there but what are you
gonna do
what are you gonna do nothing i'm just
like i'm i keep getting like i'm gonna
keep looking at the screen again
i need to do calisthenics and and all
these women are [ __ ] attacking me
because of this damn hair
[ __ ] this hair this [ __ ] wig is
like a aphrodisiac i didn't i didn't
understand it
until now thank you victor i'm seeing
the reactions to the women
i'm gonna have to get me a [ __ ] hair
system as a super poofy
super poofy effeminate [ __ ] like like
something richard sin is aware
i'd probably be popular as a
[ __ ] if i had his hair system
like that
because it's just [ __ ] as hell where's
that we'll be good
help me pick out a gay a gay wig well
because you know
that because do you know why that that
would be attractive to women is because
be like
um wow he must be like super confident
yeah
masculinity that exactly
yeah it works well you know there was of
course you know some of the legends are
like like that
nick rhodes was having an effeminate
look to nick rhodes from you know you
guys know who that is he's
he was a keyboard player really kind of
like the brains behind durand around he
had an effeminate look to him
that [ __ ] was stylish though and
it was the time
definitely not gay definitely not gay
you wouldn't know if you didn't
know him but because he kind of looked
like a gay model really
that dude was a [ __ ] hound a hound
i was so handsome little dude well i was
so really into duran
as a as a kid i still like them now he
had a great haircut man
he did and he always had fabulous
clothes and stuff and it's like it's
funny because my grandparents were
like well my grandfather mostly was just
kind of like
like okay yeah when nick was very
intelligent i'm like
they they get more chicks than you ever
guys yeah nick was very intelligent very
uh
they know something you don't know witty
witty every one of them was straight and
they were like
knocking them all down yeah they were
supermodels they went out with
supermodels
well [ __ ] man simon labonte mary i think
they all married models didn't they we
all married supermodels yeah they did
yeah
and [ __ ] simon and jasmine are still
married far as i know they've been
married like
oh my god what the hell is going on out
there yeah [ __ ] it sounds like a damn
two-stroke motorcycle
it was yeah somebody had a really
[ __ ] loud motorcycle just went by
i'm saying i look like a charming young
cherub
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love it i love it she was a knit head
nick rhodes had a beautiful face still
does they all look good
actually yeah even though they're you
know they're older guys older but they
still look really good
they're all at least 60 now huh pretty
much um
nick's got to be probably get probably
pushing it sure
because you know i was into them i got
into them when i was
probably 10 or 11. uh tammy says prince
was way feminine and super sexy
that is absolutely yep that is true that
little dude was very deceptive though he
was a predator
yeah yeah if uh if you were a female and
you were around him you were going to
give it up
that's just how it was you know you were
going to throw it at him
he evidently would have you know quite a
bit of magnetism to him of course star
power
i'm telling you man that was the end of
the old south i told that story before
yeah yeah when [ __ ] mtv and cable tv
made it to mississippi
duran duran and france and some of those
other new wave bands abc and [ __ ] that
was the end of the south
well because who the hell wants to like
live in some nowhere town with like
nothing to do
yeah and they saw that on their country
bar yeah they saw that and the [ __ ]
all the kids you know i was growing up
in that generation were like oh
okay so that's what cool is
and that was you weren't going to stay
there
so yeah it's like we didn't know what
cool was it didn't know how cool it was
until you saw it
oh okay yeah that's cool
sandra says also a touch of bob ross
instead of tom ross
happy little accidents you guys need to
stop [ __ ] about the hair man
this is a ridiculous 12 [ __ ] wig came
out of a goddamn plastic bag
it smells like a [ __ ] carpet the
carpet remember the [ __ ] carpet shops
your mom should take you to where we're
buying some new carpet you got to get a
rug and [ __ ]
that woven spun plastic smell that's
what this is [ __ ] that's way
it's not sexy
[Laughter]
but i gotta say it's a pretty [ __ ]
ball in halloween concert
i'm like i'm really glad is he [ __ ]
you that's what i want to know
is he [ __ ] you see
[ __ ] michael caine man he was always
one drink away from whipping your
[ __ ] ass because he thought you were
cheating on him
yeah cheating yeah i know you're
cheating on me [ __ ] well he wasn't even
i'm paying the bills he wasn't even an
inch away he did beat her
yeah yeah uh did he wait killed her
eventually
he killed her i don't think he was
beating her ass though well he did like
kind of yeah
wait what happened at the end of that
eventually he killed a bunch of people
but eventually he killed her
eventually that he strangled her but i
don't think he was
physically abusive [ __ ] was just
mentally
he was uptight very uptight no no fun to
be around
that's true yeah that was cut okay
let me educate you [ __ ] here we go
yeah you guys ready for an education
this is a tom ross education
you hear today all this toxic
masculinity [ __ ] coming from these girls
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about
yeah we do no they're masculinity is not
toxic
there's [ __ ] lots of good macho [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
well yeah you know and a lot of the same
women that complain that you see with
this [ __ ] kool-aid color hair they're
complaining about
they don't go out with them so soy boys
they actually like [ __ ] wild
[ __ ] on the back of motorcycles
that'll keep them in line
that's actually who they go for but the
thing is is that
that's not toxic real toxic masculinity
if you want to see it
it's in the movie the hand that
[ __ ] was pretty toxic
he was he it wasn't the strong gentle
hand
it was the selfish controlling hand
that's a lot of difference
big difference well he wasn't trying to
let a woman grow
he wasn't trying to help yeah that's
what i mean he didn't try to keep her
stifle
and he was a douche even before his hand
got exactly
it just accelerated it yeah like he was
already he just like belittled
everything
she wanted to like uh that's stupid crap
and it's like he was just always like
that it's like
toxic masculinity that's why she went
off and [ __ ] the the yoga the essence
of toxic masculinity is to control
others to keep them small so you can
feel big
yeah that's really what that's really
what the essence is
the same guys that wrote that also wrote
conan conan is the exact opposite that
was healthy masculinity if he actually
studied
he was helping women yeah and he was
um he was a man of self-sacrifice too
and
and uh he was a heroic figure well he
respected
his girlfriend like as a as an equal
well yeah well equal but different
remember he was trying to use her to get
out of the [ __ ] warrior lifestyle
have a future
so he can live forever and what
symbolically what that meant was that he
could have a family life
because you can't live forever as a
soldier you'll never get you know what i
mean eventually you'll get killed and
that's what she was offering and she was
trying to get him out of the lifestyle
and everything and he wanted to
but she died in the line of duty yeah
and then he threw the old necklace away
got the new necklace
he put the [ __ ] eye of the serpent on
remember me which is that female power
yeah type of deal of creation so then he
lived on
for her ideals yeah because we can have
babies yeah right yeah
women can create men can men can create
machines and [ __ ]
they can create friends and alliances
they can do things that can create
things
they can't create life on their own
that's that's that's that's
our weakness yeah only women can do that
women's and
[ __ ] conan not a dumb movie you go in
there and you [ __ ] it's all very
symbolic as talking about
that people laugh at it today probably
they don't understand what it is
the symbolism that they're seeing but
very well thought out conan two
conan the destroyer nah not good
yeah a little bit of a mixed bag that
one they [ __ ] it up they turned it
into a kids movie
yeah i could have done without the
little monster
thing that looked like some [ __ ] from
well the wrestling thing with the
[ __ ]
yeah yeah anyway you could have done
without that yeah yeah we have a costume
looks
cool on screen huh look at your costume
on screen
i'm just glad it came out because like i
said the [ __ ] makeup this was like
the last moment thing because like i
said i had the latex thing and i was
just like yeah this is awesome
i just pulled it off my [ __ ] face i'm
looking at myself i look like a [ __ ]
insane jim morrison
this is the end my only
friend the end yeah that makes me want
to listen to the doors
yeah with the doors you should be jim
jim morrison next year
be dressed as jim morrison yeah look i
had my shirt unbuttoned
all the way down with a big conch shell
[ __ ]
belt and the leather pants and [ __ ] is
[ __ ] [ __ ] lovely motorcycle boots
and [ __ ] yeah
but you know just little [ __ ] dude
i was like i mean i like i like your
costume this year it's like i'm always i
was always a big advocate of
i know people like to do like clever
[ __ ] like oh we're dressing up like
somebody from a movie and it's just like
a t-shirt and jeans or some [ __ ]
i'm always a big advocate of like
dressing up like something scary because
it's halloween
you know what i mean even when i was
little it's like other girls my age
would be like i'm gonna be a princess
i'm gonna do this i'm like [ __ ] that i'm
gonna be like a witch or a mummy or like
[ __ ]
everybody telling me to win wear the wig
year-round you guys are very thank you
tim
you should well you should just wear it
at random times and then just like
not say anything about it tina says jeez
i gotta re-watch conan
yeah uh conan is very deep
very deep i can walk you through conan i
actually jenny and i did a did a movie
review of conan the court the audio
quality is bad we should redo that one
day
i got to do it conan deluxe version
i've pretty much now figured out
everything the riddle of steel and
everything there's a lot of hidden
messages in there
and he calls me a nerd for like going
off into like all the david lewis it's
very niche
and it starts off with a quote from
nietzsche that which does not kill you
makes you stronger that's the [ __ ]
essence of everything
it started to tie in with my studies on
[ __ ]
uh schopenhauer you guys get some
somebody
not scoping how about shopping i wasn't
sure i wasn't schopenhauer and nietzsche
all the great german philosophers it all
started to make more sense
and then kind of you can put it in with
some of the religious mythos and stuff
but no it's
very much conan
one is very much a how-to manual how to
be a badass
and it's it it's also male and female
it shows both aspects of it
because it is it is a study in
german philosophy but it's also uh it's
gendered
also which that's true because biology
is gendered
mostly you got some people that are
intersex but
that's a special case that in some
philosophies even talk about that
the indians are big into that about
a person having character sexual
characteristic sexual characteristics
from
both sexes well in a lot of ancient
cultures like trans people were kind of
like
they were like especially yeah and
revered as being outside the normal
confines of gender but which you can see
why that would happen
because it's like that's it's like a
special case because it doesn't happen
that often
yeah what's going on right now you know
all this [ __ ] about [ __ ] identity
politics that take the [ __ ] too extreme
to try to use they're trying to
weaponize it
it's not what it is the ancients knew
about all that stuff they had a very
different explanation of it
and a lot more wisdom about it you know
a lot more wisdom
they didn't try to use these everybody's
got to get along we're all got to get
along
that's that's what reality i mean unless
you just want that's a lot of kill
[ __ ]
well no i mean i was i was actually
going to say unless you want to go off
and live on your own planet
yeah that's true right but which i
wouldn't mind doing actually be nice and
quiet up there
it's best to try to resolve conflict
peacefully if it can't be resolved then
you have to resolve it the old-fashioned
way and then it ends up being resolved
but only temporarily and that's just the
cycle of light of life
it's the circle it's the soul cycle of
it nothing's new
none of the [ __ ] we're seeing today in
the newspaper none of that shit's new
it's been going on forever uh and it's
history is not progressive or r or
regressive it's cyclical
well yeah that's why i try not to get
too upset about all this has happened
before it will happen again
yeah yeah i mean sometimes we do kind of
like make incremental progress but it's
kind of like two steps forward
you know what's most step forward two
steps back we make technologically we
make technological advances but you're
not going to advance on humans
human nature because humans are humans
and they were always humans unless like
i said
they can put some [ __ ] chip in there
right yeah and you don't want that
you don't want that you want if you're
going to change human beings you want to
do it
through altruistic and very wise genetic
engineering and it's got to be done by
the parents that are having these
children not governments
you know what i mean yeah because if two
people want to have a child you could
have the natural way if you want to do
it the unnatural way and due to genetic
engineering
only the parents would know the best
thing
traits to have for their children you
would want to have a child that'd be
like the best child you could have out
of
1 in 10 000 tries that's what you would
go for
and of course you would benefit and so
would
all of humanity would benefit if
everyone's children were the best they
could possibly be
but competition would increase there's a
lot of alphas to have at once [ __ ]
spot
so you have to have a society where
there's less people probably
that's how i i'm not sure because there
was a movie called gattaca that talked
about that
man we need to review that one of these
[ __ ] very intelligent science fiction
book called gattaca
that was what would happen if everybody
was engineered genetically engineered
well everyone wasn't that was one of the
conflicts everyone pretended they were
genetically engineered
but it was very good movie and what
would happen you know
and how would you deal with that
that's really the way to go genetic
engineering
you don't want to be merging with these
[ __ ] machines all right
you don't want you you don't want
[ __ ] ai
to run things it's too dangerous that's
just me and i read a lot of [ __ ]
frank hubert you know what i mean from
dune and
a lot of wisdom in the dune books you
know that guy was very smart frank
cooper
yeah like i said you're not sure like i
like ai up to a point but it's like it's
gonna get to a point where
you don't want ai telling you how to
live right you're going to get to a
point where it's like in the [ __ ]
terminator where they're going to be
like oh well we're robots and like we
decided that humans kind of suck and
we're so we're going to like take them
out because obviously they're inferior
or we're yeah we're we're we're [ __ ]
machine
like gods like something a 2001 a space
odyssey
and we're going to dictate to you living
creatures how to be
you don't want that either no one tells
you you want biology you want biology to
to do to do all the cool [ __ ] you know
what i mean
the human experience yeah
that's just what i'm saying but i'm just
like i'm sorry i'm just like fascinated
by our costumes like how they look on my
little screen i'm just like
i almost wish i didn't have to talk
because it kind of like ruins the
illusion like every time i open my mouth
and it's like really distracting right
but you know what are you gonna do you
uh
uh you looking at some yeah i'm
listening to seeing what they're humans
are animals and we're a lot like cats
yeah us and cats are the only animals
that kill for pleasure and not just to
eat
yeah well probably well no most animals
count to kill for pleasure i mean the
uh killer whales were doing it whales do
that
animals aren't very nice to other
species
you know um now species killing each
other
human behavior is very much like the
[ __ ] great apes uh chimpanzees kill
each other and bonobos bonobos
bonobos are all they're [ __ ] those
[ __ ] little things well yeah we're
like
we're like a midway point between those
two species
and strangely enough gorillas as big as
they are actually a lot more chilled out
than um champs humans are yeah chimps
are a little aggro
yeah well i've heard people describe
what it's like being attacked in africa
being attacked
by [ __ ] share your [ __ ] dick right
off by chimpanzee males and they
and the guy was fighting this five and a
half foot tall [ __ ] chimpanzee
strong as [ __ ] and he just had just
killed his african god
this african guy threw it threw himself
in the path of this [ __ ] champ that
[ __ ] chimp just bit him up
and he said he said just looking at that
thing was like looking into the [ __ ]
looking into that chimpanzee's face was
like looking into hell
he said it was like looking at the face
of a demon
and just pure rage and hatred
and humans are very chimp-like
you know what i mean but like i said we
also have bonobo like yeah
right because those two species are very
very closely related and we are
98 the same as those two
we just happen to have genetic gifts
that make us [ __ ] look the way we do
and also we have films yeah
and we have a better intellect than they
have in terms of you know
in terms of some you know the ability to
control emotions and stuff
they don't control them as well although
intellectually
chimpanzees can remember series as a
[ __ ]
uh of shapes and objects their memories
are better than ours
yeah they're they're short-term memory
for sure is better than ours they have a
very good intelligence it's just
different than ours
um we're more of a generalized
intelligence and tool makers that made
us different than them
uh it's all spooky [ __ ] you know what i
mean and for people that are big into
religions and theology they don't want
to talk about you know how
the idea that man is an animal but
that's not really saying anything bad
about us that's
we have to yeah it's like we are animals
yeah it's like that's not
that's not a [ __ ] insult because i
like animals
i remember when i was a kid you know
back in the 70s and 80s oh don't say
that you know i mean that was i know i
remember people saying that
i was like no no we're we're animals but
animals are pretty cool
i mean yeah uh they have their own
personalities and everything but
uh it's just something we have to come
to terms with of what we are
you know and i think we're cool i'm just
saying you know
we're imperfect and i still i like that
because if [ __ ] was perfect it'd be too
easy
and your life would be on autopilot and
you wouldn't be controlling [ __ ] or
making any decisions
you'd be like a computer program going
through the most efficient route and it
would it wouldn't be as fun
you know what i mean yeah it's like
you know life sucks for a lot of people
i'm not saying that but it's like
you know you do need something to do and
like some kind of challenge in your life
um you know to kind of overcome
yeah so we're living in the best time in
history
the most tumultuous time time in the
best [ __ ] technological
progress there's a promising time in
[ __ ]
in the history of mankind we're just
within reach of mars and venus
and space travel you know what i mean
[ __ ] spacex is like i watch these
rockets launch from my bedroom window
there it's right here we'd be sitting in
there we hear that boom what was that
remember that it was this damn rock
there's so many that we forgot
we forget about them and uh we'll be on
mars
soon because it'll rattle your windows
10 years from now you know as old as i
am you know what i mean for all i know i
might be
my first [ __ ] to die on mars
would be like i'd be like
musk i'm ready to go bro i'll throw my
jacket down
all my [ __ ] all my [ __ ]
accomplishments are like say look this
is all the agencies i work for
send me the bars i'll be the first man
to die on mars i go up there for a life
sentence on mars but it would only be
five six years
what difference would it make i might go
when you go would you go like let's
spend the final years on mars
i would think about it yeah but here's
the thing they're saying well
some that was actually kind of an old
concept that mars might be a one-way
trip
that [ __ ] spacex spaceship that
they're making
it'd be easy to bring you back what'd it
say four months
no it was like nine months i think well
still it's not that
long though that's less than a year yeah
less than a year
that's the j yeah i could sleep for that
i know you could yeah that's the
gestation period for a human being yeah
so yeah yeah that's like nothing and
it's getting cheaper and cheaper and
the older you get the quicker nine
months the quicker nine months is yeah
it's like yeah let's go
we have fun because [ __ ] man i remember
last halloween like it was [ __ ]
yesterday
when i was carving the pumpkin today i'm
like holy crap i can't believe it's been
a year since i was
let's see what the crowd is saying read
them off jenny let's talk about the uh
let's talk about what the
maria says you both look great your
makeup is
is impressive since i can't do halloween
this year i'm enjoying yeah it's like i
haven't actually got to do a really good
costume for a couple and i only just
thought of this like a couple weeks ago
when i ordered all the [ __ ]
because i was inspired because he's like
well i'm going to be michael caine from
the hand and i was like
oh we should do like because i don't
know if you guys know but there's a
shirt called welcome to the basement and
they do like
um movie reviews and stuff they like
talk about them they kind of riff on
them like a little bit like mst it's
really good
and um they every year for their
halloween shows
they dress up as characters from
movies that they reviewed like in the
past season they've been on for like 10
years or something
and i was like oh well since you're
being the dude from the hand it's like
i'm gonna be
vampire amy from fright night because we
reviewed that because this was actually
a costume i was considering
last year i just didn't get around to it
and i didn't get it put together
so yeah taylor was in there saying that
she needs to um
re-watch conan and she remembers grace
jones on there
yeah that was on conan the destroyer
that was the second one
the second one was very different than
the first one the first one was kind of
like a serious movie it had a lot of
symbolism and stuff the second one was
actually
more kind of like the marvel comics it
was a little goofy it was a little goofy
now there were there was a series of
marvel comics and there was a character
in there that she was based on
there was a character in the marvel
comics called zula
who was a she was a female african-style
barbarian warrior girl she was like that
and that's what that
grace jones was the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
she was the [ __ ] i always really
liked grace if you didn't grow up during
that period you wouldn't understand it
she was part of the of the new wave
scene that was coming on
i think she was from where was she from
jamaica or haiti
i can't remember now but she kind of
came in with the british new wave
yeah and she was [ __ ] big with the
[ __ ] new wave
oh yeah seeing dudes she ended up
marrying dolph
back dolph lundgren i think yeah back
when dolph was [ __ ] hot he
he he he's got his [ __ ] back together
now but
oracle says jamaica jamaica yeah so you
gotta write the person
she was a [ __ ] great artist among
herself she could sing really well if
you've ever seen any of her live
performances
she did them up until recently they're
they're on youtube she could sing
she did some weird [ __ ] art nouveau
kind of [ __ ] news that's why i licked
her like i love all that weird [ __ ] that
was like one thing
like people do weird [ __ ] nowadays but
it's like in the 80s it almost seemed
like
people hadn't done that [ __ ] before so
it was like people were just like wait
like look at somebody like klaus know me
for crazy yeah it was like mixing like
new wave and opera for [ __ ] sake
and it's like nobody had ever seen that
before and so i feel like now
everybody's seen everything
because everybody's done everything very
striking she was in a view to a kill
of james bond uh she had a [ __ ] very
unique
beauty her face was almost kind of
almost like an aryan face
she almost looked german but she had a
flat top that was a [ __ ]
uh like an afro it looked [ __ ] great
she would be one she reminds us of our
friend who's our friend
what does uh [ __ ] um storm at [ __ ]
universal
oh that's right yeah we haven't seen her
in a long time i've seen her a long time
probably one of the [ __ ] best-looking
black women i've ever [ __ ] seen as a
friend of ours what was her name
she just showed up to the club we got
pictures of her jenny what they're
[ __ ] rubbing on her ass and [ __ ]
remember that what was this oh yeah
that's right i have a picture
of me yeah she's about what six foot
tall yeah she's very original she's kind
of like a
grace jones bald or she was yeah i
haven't seen her in a while
she married a white dude named spider
who did all the [ __ ] um
paintings and all the murals for a
friend of ours that owns uh gods and
comics so there's a gods of monsters
and monsters don't know
yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man what was there
[ __ ]
crystal crystal crystal yeah i haven't
seen crystal forever
she was a chick like crystal crystal
crystal and grace jones were a lot alike
they do look like
a little bit of light a little bit a
little bit crystal's a little
crystal's a little bit more mixed than
grace though grace is [ __ ] like look
like straight from africa
real dark skin only thing i could say
critical about grace is that she
didn't have she wasn't real shapely she
was just
tall and thin supermodel he doesn't like
one
i don't like that one girl saw her boobs
yeah i'm not into that although i liked
grace jones
but she was just tall and [ __ ] thin
she looked like she was about 6'1 at
least huh
yeah she was very tall real tall right
but she was pretty good looking and she
had a [ __ ] interesting personality
well that's her whole like [ __ ] thing
was cool
yeah you know what i mean like i said in
in a way that's we've kind of talked
about this before but it's like
you know it doesn't so much matter what
you look like but if you have like a
whole
thing that you're doing like a whole
look and you have like a cool
personality that goes along with it that
actually goes a long way
you don't have to be like yeah i think
grace's main [ __ ]
main reason why she stood out is because
she was jamaican so she didn't have kind
of like
she wasn't trapped in kind of like the
african-american paradigm of that time
she was free to do whatever the [ __ ] she
wanted to do and she was very [ __ ]
um like free-spirited
she was whatever she wanted to be she
wasn't she was in her own scene
well i do kind of feel like like i said
there was kind of a time in the 70s and
80s
where and i guess now like now it's kind
of like old hat people are just like
whatever you just like do your thing
yeah you do but in the 80s that was kind
of like a big deal
right yeah like for somebody to come out
and just be like i mean
remember the [ __ ] freak out that
everybody had like when annie lennox
like came out and she was like with her
man's suit and she had like the
crew cut yeah everything like that she
looks like a man
yeah so everybody's like freaking out
about it and then like like she's
cute it's cute as hell man she's
beautiful she's beautiful and you know
you know who looks just like annie
lennox
sophie if you put a [ __ ] red flat top
on sophie that that that's exactly how
it [ __ ] seems yeah sophia are you out
there yeah you do actually really look
like annie leonard i told her i
shouldn't analytics is like a beautiful
yeah i showed her that [ __ ] video and
she's like oh yeah she had a [ __ ]
beautiful yeah
holy crap yeah so it has a beautiful
voice yeah that's talking about her like
she's dead or something
i would think yeah so i kind of i kind
of see grace jones as kind of like an
auntie atlantic's
real similar real similar i was going to
say too because ken mentioned like boy
george and i
it's funny because i remember like old
people
freaking freaking out about boy george
back in the day but it's like i was you
know i was a kid growing up in the 80s
um you know i was a preteen teenager and
i was just kind of like okay i suppose
so
no one really like thought about it it's
like okay
he kind of looks like a woman he's maybe
he's gay maybe you sleep with the
drummer like nobody cared
you know what i'm saying yeah but it's
like for old people are like flipping
out about it i remember
because they were you know like i said
my grandpa my grand my grandfather
yeah i like annie lettick she was like
she had that look kind of
well i think it was kind of also kind of
like that spiritual vibe
yeah because people were breaking into
new ground and doing their own thing
they were going outside the normal
paradigm
where they were dictating who they were
yeah they wouldn't allow themselves
to deal with it yeah they weren't
allowing people that was a great thing
about the 80s
people were trying to break it out of
breaking out of those pigeonholed
[ __ ]
concepts of who is supposed to be what
you know what i mean that includes all
the people from the new wave
british new wave is the british people
the american people jamaicans whatever
the people trying to just say no to the
old stereotypes and making something
totally new and unique yeah that's cool
which like i said i'm
you know you have to like think that
nowadays because everyone's so kind of
like open to that which i'm which is
good like i'm down with that
but that's kind of where it came from
and you have to think too that like
in the 80s it was like not okay yeah it
wasn't okay back then
no so you know you came out like looking
like boy george
you would get your ass kicked even in
well even in the late 80s and
early 90s like because i graduated from
high school in 1990 and i had a friend
in high school
who he was not super effeminate looking
but he had like big
like robert smith hair and he wore
eyeliner he got his ass kicked like
weekly yeah you weren't supposed to do
that
they did it anyway though even though he
was the nicest dude ever
well it was kind of like freddie mercury
coming out [ __ ] just straight up
dressing like a woman with a damn
mustache on
yeah video remember that i want to be
free yeah that was like well like i
honestly knew what it was a huge [ __ ]
statement back then like nowadays
everyone's like oh okay
yeah not back then do you but yeah back
then it was like you might get [ __ ]
killed if you did
in the real world you would he was doing
that only on a tv screen
in the real world you get your [ __ ]
stomped unless you were out in
california
like i said but now all that shit's been
democratized you could pretty much do
that kind of [ __ ] anywhere you want to
now which is getting international
and cable changed it that's good and a
lot of people [ __ ] all these
young people have not recognized how
much [ __ ] has changed
and for the better you know what i mean
let people just do it
be whatever they want to be you know
what i mean it doesn't have anything to
do with you
you know i mean like i see some people
acting crazy
hey man that's them that doesn't have
anything to do with me you know what i
mean as long as they're not telling me
how to live i'm happy
yeah i'm kind of like on that ship as
well yeah just don't tell me how dj
maniac says all the gods and mansonites
got their asses kicked when i was in
high school yep and i was only
five years behind you jenny yeah yep i
graduated in 1990 yeah oh yeah
if you look like a goth or especially if
you were a dude and you looked in any
way like a feminine
or like new wavy or anything oh my god
you would so get your ass kicked yep
it's why i'm so it's why even to this
day i am so
not into like jocks and it was like that
but it was always kind of like that even
back in the hippie days yeah people if
you were looked a little hippie they'd
come after you
well yeah i came out of the army and
[ __ ] i was big into the [ __ ]
god scene when i got out of the army it
was [ __ ] going big it was 1994.
and yeah you'd get some [ __ ] but i was
in [ __ ] boston at the time
and even in boston they'd give you some
[ __ ] but i didn't give a [ __ ]
you get yeah i got i grew
man ray was a hello [ __ ] club and
[ __ ] if you wanted to go to man ray
it was like
our version of studio 54 you had to look
a certain way to get through that
[ __ ]
get through those front doors because
you had a doorman you know what i mean
like i have a camera chainer looking
like this remember back in the day when
they actually used to have dress codes
yeah dress cuz the door man so i kind of
wish that they still have
yeah so you know i'm [ __ ]
i'm still friends with all the [ __ ]
djs the javier and everything and that's
that's that's where i came up and that
was actually post
service i was coming out of the army and
getting a hard time on the [ __ ]
subway going to that club i'd give
i didn't give a [ __ ] i did not give a
[ __ ] you have to
really i mean you have to i i kind of
learned very young like just not to
give a [ __ ] i i was kind of lucky
because i'm a girl so you're not going
to get your ass kicked
as readily like i got picked on a lot
but mostly like you wouldn't get
physically [ __ ] on like dudes would just
kind of like harass you or like
follow you or try to like grab your
boobs or [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean which is bad
but like i said dudes that were into
that kind of [ __ ] like i had some
friends in high school that
they didn't even look like effeminate
quote-unquote they just looked like
gothi they had like eyeliner and like
big hair and stuff and
like they would get their asses beat
like all the time well it's 5 50. jenny
should we go ahead and start this case
i know it's like we haven't even holy
crap we're already an hour well it's the
halloween special
halloween special you know you know what
i'm saying and like i said i keep
getting
distracted by it's um how much i
probably have like
a third okay of the cup left
i haven't been chugging it too much are
you like he's gonna get drunk
just like michael caine and he's gonna
like start smacking with
me with the hand and [ __ ] is he [ __ ]
you
that's the question well who's the he
that we're talking about
thank you out running errands oh hey we
said like hey you're our newest patron
so hey there there
yeah we gave you a shout out bro i think
it's a girl
i can't see
[Laughter]
it's all the same is he [ __ ] you
that's the question is he [ __ ] we're
all just humans yeah yeah
oh my god if people haven't seen the
movie the hand
they will have no idea what you're
talking about yeah where i'm coming from
people i got another one thank you
[Laughter]
what's he saying what do you say it's a
she it's a she did she say
she said happy fantastic halloween
i can't see them blind don't have my
glasses on don't put your glasses on
well i just
i had to put my glasses on it like ruins
the costume like you can't even see what
makes a costume i can't see
you can't even see my fantastic [ __ ]
contacts i even
found they're not exactly the same as
amy's from fright night
but cause hers were like glass and they
were like super big and they were like
[ __ ] yellow with red in the middle
but i did find like some yellow and red
ones that were
you know close enough i'm like
he always he got on my case because he's
like he's like dude you look fine it's
like you were because i was like at the
last minute i'm like
oh my god this is like sticking my hair
and it's like doing this and that
because you know how i do
and it's like look if i'm gonna do a
halloween costume i'm not gonna half-ass
the [ __ ] i'm gonna do it like and i'm
just
i'm still mad that i didn't get to do
like the vampire bites
what show everyone in your chest what's
that show everyone
[Laughter]
oh no oh no oh
no oh my god
this is we're only an hour in this is
gonna get drastically wrong
i can already tell we haven't even got
to the [ __ ] topic yet yeah so
all right so kahn says he's never seen
the hand
we did a review of it a while back um
it's really good actually it's it's one
of
i don't remember if it was oliver
stone's first movie or it's one of his
very early ones
and it's based on a novel called the
lizards tale i think
and uh yeah as tom was saying earlier
it's kind of an exploration of toxic
masculinity
but uh he's got his little he's got his
hand down there it's on the floor
thank you khan i didn't know if anybody
would know like i
i looked for like [ __ ] makeup
tutorials on this [ __ ] like on the mouth
there was only like two and they're both
kind of shitty
but hopefully this one came out
okay i'm not really sure like i think i
my hair at least looks better than
theirs because they didn't even get like
curly wigs they just have like straight
[ __ ] bright wigs
all right so now that we're an hour into
the [ __ ] show
and it's still light out which is crazy
and i don't know what am i doing
who knows where are you we haven't got
any trick-or-treaters i don't know if
we're going to get any trick-or-treaters
this year
but it's not dark yet yeah but like
little little kids would probably still
oh my god it's like every time i see you
i just like
it it's just cracking me up but it's
just like so
what
are you mad because are you mad
are you mad because because someone else
is [ __ ] you
it's like this is going to do yeah is he
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
although i'm a vampire so if you guys
haven't seen the movie you got to see it
man it's like a good movie
the hand he loses his head in the
[ __ ] car wreck
seriously that stretches me the [ __ ]
that scene
stayed with me my whole [ __ ] life me
too i could barely put my
hand outside that's our window that
movie was why i would never put my hand
outside the window
like afterward yeah i was nine years old
when that came out
and i saw it and i was just like nope
and i was just like
every time i was in the car because that
[ __ ] stressed me out so much
connor watson calling me tom sancho
morrison
you're the second person that said that
yeah
but yeah like any movie that had uh
decapitation or
limbs being removed really really
stressed me out when i was a kid that's
so i feel like that's probably like a
deep-seated fear of mine
being decapitated or having like a limb
cut off
because i think that would be like
really really weird to like look down
and like see your hand and it's like not
attached to your body anymore
that like i don't know that's like
really like people are asking about the
hand
people haven't seen it the hand is
oliver stone movie
about a [ __ ] artist who was drawing
some drawing a comic strip kind of like
conan
it's because oliver stone was working on
conan at that time
um he loses his hand in an accident
and then the hand goes around and kills
people that piss him off
but there's a lot more to it than that
it has
it's about toxic masculinity
it is that's what it's about yeah yeah
and then you don't know
is the hand really out there or is it a
psychic force
that's killing his enemies or is it he's
delusional is he doing it and he's
thinking the hand is doing it you don't
know
it's a it's uh it's a classic movie from
the [ __ ] late 70s or
earlier really good and i feel like it
was one that i saw when i was oliver
stone man oliver stone
it was one that i saw when i was a kid
and like i said it made a big impression
because anything that had like
beheadings or
like the omen or something or had like
somebody's limbs getting cut off
that like really stuck with me because
that's like something that's really
scary to me
yeah so that like stayed with me all
this time and it's like i'm surprised
that a lot of people don't talk about it
because it's actually
really really good [ __ ]
it's a great movie showed it to sophie
sophie liked it she's like oh that's a
good movie
she she actually felt sorry for uh the
michael caine character
i didn't she was like yeah i meant well
i'm a bit
i'm a bigger big girl i'm a bigger [ __ ]
than soviets yeah things are very gray
by several degrees you know is the wife
[ __ ] him over or is it just his
[ __ ]
viewpoint of you you don't know i think
he was
a dick you know i think i think that's
what it was i think he was a dick
i didn't feel sorry for him and um but
you just got to see it
almost kind of like almost like alfred
hitchcock movie when you think about it
isn't it yeah i kind of you know anyway
no
i just look like a drama i kind of want
to read the book actually yeah it was
good
because me oh i wonder if it's because i
have kindle unlimited i wonder if like
somebody let me like read the [ __ ]
e-book
the thing about it is he loses one woman
but he gets a much younger one but he
[ __ ] that up too
so it's it's it's toxic masculinity
you know that's what i mean that's what
you [ __ ] up yeah you just gotta that's
what we're talking about [ __ ] dudes
man it's like you had like a perfectly
lovely woman and you treated her like
crap
and then she was like [ __ ] this i'm
gonna go sleep with my yoga instructor
because you're always like belittling me
and he's like fine with every [ __ ] off
[ __ ]
and then he finds this other like one of
his students like pretty much
jumps on his dick essentially yeah she
jumps on she just loves him
well i mean he [ __ ] that up too yeah
but that
i mean she was just [ __ ] everybody
and he wasn't like
prepared to deal with somebody she was
afraid
she wasn't that's what i mean he wasn't
prepared to deal with a woman who was
just kind of like yeah
i just kind of want like dick and i'm
not worried about like i don't want to
get all serious about
right yeah he wasn't like he wanted to
do that but he wasn't prepared to deal
with the woman that would do that
you just got to see it for yourself make
your own judgment which is crazy
yeah but yeah it's a yeah it's a really
good movie
um so are we going to talk about murders
do what you want to do do what i want to
do what you want to do
um yeah oh michael uh michael shafer
says jerry dandridge and billy cole in
fright night were supposed to be gay
i got that as well um even though this
came out in 1985 and they didn't
specifically say that
um i did pick up on that subtext
you couldn't really say that outright in
1985
um so i get that but that i did
even though i was only holy [ __ ] how old
was that i was 13 at the time
and i was probably 13 or 14 when i saw
fright night and
i got that uh when they were doing it
but like i said you can't
you couldn't say that nowadays you could
but back then you couldn't
um but that's definitely like what they
were implying
sure
all right do we talk about murders
go ahead okay i didn't know what you
were doing like i'm reading well because
sometimes
i'm i sometimes i'm afraid that i'm
going to start talking about stuff and
then you're going to be like
oh look at what the person yeah
all right so what i did i started
looking up
because like i said we're doing the
patreon polls
for all the so i did a patreon poll for
the halloween uh
episode also and overwhelmingly the
choice was talk about
murders that happened on halloween so
that's what we're going to do
even though like i said not super fun
not a super fun topic hold on one second
we'll try see
one second i knew it out running aaron
said it wasn't a realistic movie because
that student was too hot for him you
have not seen the [ __ ]
horse world the shit's [ __ ]
ridiculous even hot girls can have daddy
issues yeah that's [ __ ] ridiculous
i've seen
i've seen [ __ ] shriners
who are [ __ ] in their 50s fat and
[ __ ] ugly
all right who could barely speak english
nailing underage girls and and 19 year
olds and 17 and 18 year old hotties
because they knew all about horses so
could an art teacher who was uh 50
and he was kind of famous yeah he was
kind of famous a [ __ ]
21 or 22 year old oh you're [ __ ]
right you're [ __ ]
and you also have to you house after
that too that she
that he was her teacher yeah and some
chicks have like a thing they have a
thing for
teachers and [ __ ] trainers and
[ __ ] anyone who's put
that's like kind of authority figure or
teacher over there hell yeah
hell yeah you're crazy but no there was
a dude
i'm not gonna name him but there's a
[ __ ] brazilian horse trainer that i
know
got in trouble many times with the
[ __ ] law for going for these [ __ ]
young teenage girls
the parents complain the girls don't
complain but the parents complain
nothing ever [ __ ] happened to him
this dude was [ __ ] looked like a
goddamn walking turtle
i mean he just [ __ ] ugly
turtles yeah i'm just saying walking on
two legs look like a guitar walking on
two legs
a two-legged turn like a two-legged turn
short fat and ugly
hitting [ __ ] teenage hobbies like it
was nothing
but they were throwing them and i saw it
i worked in the same barns with him at
times they were throwing themselves at
him
yeah yeah well like i said
some hot girls have daddy's yeah hot
girls with daddy issues
and yeah they we're not talking about 12
year olds or anything we're talking
about
17 yeah yeah they're not like miners
obviously
that would be [ __ ] up right they're
old enough to like oh nothing to know
exactly what that
is yeah you know yeah so
so yeah he was hitting the [ __ ] 21 or
22 25 year old
oh yeah hell yeah so yeah michael caine
could have got that
in that teacher role [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
i didn't find that particularly
unbelievable
yeah that happens because like i said
there there is a type of girl that
that's totally into that that likes the
teachers the the dirty old man thing and
everything
yeah yeah well and like i said she
wasn't
into him like oh i love you like forever
she was [ __ ] that other dude too
we go to the club and got 18 19 19 20 21
year old girls hitting on her
guys hitting on her in the 18 19 21 yeah
[ __ ] right these these dudes are
coming up on this [ __ ] milf porn
with these [ __ ] hot porn stars and
i'm always like dude they're in their
50s with the [ __ ] big boobs i should
be your mom
yeah it's not like it was so weird just
go look up
look look at ryan connor ryan connor's
my age that woman's [ __ ] unbelievable
and you got [ __ ] 18 17 18 year old
dudes [ __ ] gunner for that
she probably wouldn't have anything to
do with it but a lot of women don't
don't don't date down too much but yeah
because
i mean they're they don't have anything
they're having money yeah well
no if they don't have any money they
don't have any experience they don't
have any
that's what i mean it'll be just like oh
two minutes later be like oh it's over
yeah right good for you they got [ __ ]
50 year old
when i was a kid back in the 80s the
idea of a 50 year old super hot porn
star that just didn't exist
yeah but it does now well yeah when
you're a kid you think of 50 they're
yeah you know that's all
well no those women didn't exist yeah
they weren't in the business and they
just weren't being promoted and
the drugs and the surgery you need to
look like that didn't exist back then
true because ryan connor taking [ __ ]
hgh and [ __ ] sarms
breast implants and works out they
didn't have that when i was a kid
women didn't work out they didn't lift
weights yeah that's true you know
but uh they're doing [ __ ] porn and
they
[ __ ] she's like 55 56 she looks great
well [ __ ] i mean look even look at some
like hollywood actresses yeah
that are like older than you think they
are 60 60 something years old
yeah they still look [ __ ] fantastic
it's like you know surgery
and like [ __ ] like that money a lot yeah
money and working out
knowledge and drugs they're taking
they're taking research chemicals
yeah yeah you know if i had the money
i'd probably do that too but i don't
yeah you could
but i go cute
but the thing is like i don't feel like
i don't feel like even though i'm almost
50 i feel like i don't
look that you don't you don't you don't
look old
you know what i mean your face held
together pretty unless i'm
deluding myself i hope not yeah but
you know like i said it's kind of
genetic because my mom looked really
young too like
well into her [ __ ] 50s so i'm kind of
yeah
i dated a man 23 24 year olds older than
me
when i was 24 and i think it and i think
i've worked out my daddy issues did a
guy five years
younger than me and well and i wasn't
and it wasn't fun
okay um i went out before i went out
with you
i went out with a dude who was 11 years
younger than me
and he's pretty rad actually yeah
[Laughter]
but i like people who aren't i like
people who are kind of like
ageless you know what i mean because i
didn't actually
it didn't actually occur to me when i
was first like
meeting up with him and talking that he
was that much younger than i was j
maniac said when he first saw you he
thought you were a teenager and that i
was your dad
no way motherfucker's [ __ ]
no way yeah i'm so [ __ ] old yeah he's
[ __ ]
we're not that far we're not that far
apart no you're only a couple years old
three two or three am i i okay you were
born in 69
i was born in 72. so yeah three years
three years ago three years i just
turned 48
at the end of september but like i said
i try to like i don't try to do anything
i don't like i don't do anything like
special
i just like wash my face and put lotion
on it that's bad that's all i've ever
done
every now and then i put some vaseline
on my lips keep them from cracking
that's about that's i don't that's my
beauty regime
so i don't know i don't know but uh yeah
so you want to talk about some murders
before i get too [ __ ] drunk to talk
about [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dan says my daughter is 19 so that's why
i have that opinion
okay dead [ __ ] serious
well thank you but yeah seriously
we are like almost the same age um but
yeah
like i said i think a lot of it's
genetics because my mom had the same
[ __ ] happen
like she got she divorced my dad years
ago
and even when she was like in her late
30s early 40s she would go to the bar
with her friends and like she would get
like
high school dudes and college dudes like
hitting on her not knowing that she was
like old enough to be their mom
and that's what that's what i always say
it's like every now and then if we go
out to the bar and like some [ __ ]
19 year old like comes out it's like
super weird i'm like
you like into your like [ __ ] your
mind that's weird i don't know
it's just weird to me but yeah all right
so
like i said there were an alarming
amount of
murders that happen on halloween as it
happens
um so i decided to i decided to keep it
to four cases and i was just kind of
like well
i didn't want ones that were just gonna
be like oh somebody happened to get
killed on halloween i wanted to be like
hollering
halloween related you know what i'm
saying
so these are the ones i picked and i
they're i'm doing them in chronological
order
you all right yeah okay i i might need
another drink
okay here i'm gonna get a drink hold on
saunders says did your skin get better
after you stopped smoking
um i didn't notice that much difference
but i hadn't been smoking here's the
terrible thing
i actually didn't start smoking until i
was probably in my 30s
like because when i was like in my 20s
and 30s and everything
i didn't drink i didn't smoke i didn't
do any of that [ __ ]
i didn't start doing that [ __ ] until i
was probably like
36 maybe um just because i was kind of
like man i was such a nerd
like when i was younger maybe i should
like go have some fun
so i started drinking more
um i didn't really start smoking until i
hooked up with tom because he was at
that time he was um
a really bad smoker so i was kind of
like oh okay like i had smoked clothes
like before that
like you'd go to the i didn't smoke at
home but like you'd go to the club and
then you'd be like oh i'll get some
clothes and i'll smoke a couple like
while i'm at the club like while i'm
drinking
so i would do that but i wouldn't really
think about it the rest of the time
but then like hanging out with tom um
i actually started smoking like
regularly when i was like buying my own
[ __ ]
and uh so that went on so i probably
only smoked for maybe
six or seven years and then he quit
and i didn't really want to quit but
then i was kind of like well
okay so then he started vaping and i
started vaping like a month
later and now it's like every now and
then i'll be out at the club and like
i'll be like
really drunk and somebody be like hey
you want a cigarette i'm like [ __ ] yeah
i want a cigarette
but it's like the rest of the time i
don't really think about it you know
what i mean
and i stopped vaping too and so did he
go to the restaurant oh thank you
so i didn't really notice much of a
change to be honest with you
um i don't know if it's because
i didn't start young um
like i said when i was younger i didn't
really do anything
i didn't even really start drinking
until i was older and i didn't start
smoking until i was older so it might
just be that i i feel like the younger
because tom started smoking when he was
oh i don't want to say but like i think
he was like much younger when he started
smoking
so maybe that's what it is i didn't
start till i was older
so yeah um
tom vapes a lot maybe that helps um
actually the thing about
that is that the day that tom started
vaping
he stopped smoking which i never thought
would happen
because tom was he had been smoking
since he was a kid
he was super into it he would smoke at
least a pack a day
and then for him to just be like oh i'm
gonna try vaping and see if it works and
then for him to like try vaping one day
and he's like yeah i don't really want
to smoke anymore that was like amazing
i know that doesn't work that way for
everybody
but it does um it does kind of like help
you with the emotional kind of [ __ ]
because
you don't have you know when you're out
or when you're like just bored or
whatever
and it's like you want to like pick up a
cigarette and smoke it it's like you
have this other thing that you can just
kind of like puff on and it kind of like
you know satiates that need so i guess
that kind of like works for him
and so he basically has
i don't think he's had a cigarette since
then and that was like
i don't even remember how many years ago
that was i think it was like
but three maybe four years ago i think
it was four years ago
and he just like basically he just
stopped
in one day i was telling him how you
stopped smoking
yeah like the day that you started
vaping stop smoking in one day
who was a bloody mary good huh yay
thought you'd like that well like i said
i want to get into like halloween spirit
man yeah
it's like it's still not even dark yet
man i know like you opened the door and
i was kind of like oh my god it's still
light out this is like so [ __ ] weird
i thought it was like [ __ ] midnight
it feels like midnight
because i've been working on this
costume for so long um
so you want to talk about mergers yeah
okay you're running this [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] this chicken
am i you're [ __ ] this chicken not me
you run
[Laughter]
i'm just doing that because it looks
better like my mouth
so like i said when i do it what i did
was i picked
four specifically halloween murders and
i put them in chronological order
and yes we are gonna talk about the dude
that inspired all the urban legends
about how all your [ __ ] halloween
candy is poisoned yes we are gonna talk
about that crime
but not first because that wasn't
chronologically first
the first we're going to talk about
happened in 1957.
this was the murder of peter fabiano
it's halloween night 1957. this is in
california
peter fabiano who was a hairdresser
he hears his doorbell ring at a little
after 11 p.m
on halloween night so like you do
on halloween you hear the doorbell you
open the door because you think it's
some [ __ ] looking for candy right
so he opens the door and he says it's a
little late for this
isn't it so
what happens okay so there's somebody
standing on his doorstep
who clearly looks like an adult
they are wearing like this weird they
have like they painted their face like
all garish and they have like this
domino mask on they're like kind of
checkered and um has just
their clothes were just like blue jeans
like a khaki jacket it doesn't look like
a costume in any sense of the
word they have red gloves on also which
is kind of weird
and this person who is standing on the
doorstep is holding up this like paper
bag
right so this person just says to him he
answers the door and he's like it's a
little late for this isn't it like
trick-or-treating
and this person says no
and then the person on the doorstep just
shoots the dude
damn so yeah
um so
so the shot rings out peter fabiano has
a wife
she rushes to the front door the killer
is already run off
and peter has been shot and
is laying there bleeding in the entryway
now the wife's name is betty and she is
this
by all accounts super beautiful
redheaded woman
she calls the police and she's like look
some trick-or-treater came to her house
at 11
o'clock at night rang the doorbell and
then shot my husband so what the [ __ ]
she tells the police that she's 36 which
they would later find out is
not true um she also had two teenage
children from a previous
marriage now as i said pete her husband
um he had actually served in world war
ii he was a veteran
um and he later opened a beauty salon
and his whole thing like he was into
like doing all the hair and stuff and he
even
did his wife's hair all the time and
like i said she was known
kind of as this big beauty this is in uh
sun valley california as i said
now this crime which
the media dubbed the trick-or-treat
murder
um was a mystery for a little while
until the police started looking into
the motivations
of the beautiful red-headed betty who
was the wife
of the dude that got shot now let's go
back in time a little bit
so there's this woman named goldeen
goldeen you guys he has some [ __ ] there
isn't that fantastic i love that [ __ ]
name so her name is goldane piser
she was 40 year 43 years old and she was
a
medical secretary now
it would turn out spoiler alert that she
was the one
that had killed peter fabiano but there
was a whole [ __ ] story behind this
[ __ ]
so goldeen um she was kind of like
she also had red hair but a little bit
more
uh the the newspapers called her
matronly
which means fat not nice yeah
yeah just like fat and not attractive
that's kind of what they're
saying with that it's it's a diplomatic
way of saying it
so she um actually had
been working at um
she had been working at the uh hair
salon that peter papiano owns
now she there she ended up meeting this
woman
named joan rebelle who was 40.
now jen rebelle and uh goldeen
i just love saying that name they lived
like only like a block apart right
so joan they don't know a great deal
about her
um she's kind of like a mystery woman in
this
but the thing about joan she
also worked at the hair salon where
peter worked and also where betty worked
now the speculation is that
joan um saw the beautiful
red-headed betty who was the wife of
peter fabiano the murdered
party and those two
that was like some beautiful lesbian
action
happening there just like that's the
implication and this was 1957
so you couldn't really say that outright
like you know what i mean like two
ladies couldn't be in love
so that [ __ ] come on they did but you
couldn't like
say it out loud so they had they had all
these like euphemisms
and [ __ ] for it that's back in the 20s
that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
popular that's in europe
no one's saying that it's been going on
since like humans existed
yeah i'm just saying that in 1957
you couldn't come right out and say that
joan
was in love with betty yeah but it does
seem that that was the case
so evidently looking into the crime what
it seems happened
was that betty who also worked at this
hair salon
had confided in joan that
pete her husband was allegedly
abusive i don't know if he's physically
abusive emotionally abusive
something like that but the way that she
talked about it
kind of made joan be like i'mma kill
this [ __ ]
except she didn't want to kill this
[ __ ]
she got her friend goldeen who i
mentioned earlier
hey how about you um
go whack a dude well we're not gonna pay
you
she didn't get paid which to me is very
strange
like i don't think that they paid her
damn
joan just basically said hey you're my
friend and this dude
kind of sucks so don't kill him i'll
she like joan like bought her a gun and
then was like here's where their house
is
like just go there on halloween like in
a costume and just blow his face off
and joan was like okay
she did it damn she didn't even need any
money
they were all crazy to begin with
they were all crazy i'm just saying if
this was a situation if i was at work
with some woman and she was like hey i
married this dude and he really sucks
and it's like i wish somebody would kill
him
yeah it's like somebody would need to
give me a lot
of money yeah a lot of money
and have a plan for me to like like an
escape plan like an exit plan
like something yeah these people don't
sound all that bright
well clearly because the whole like plot
was [ __ ]
um yeah was uncovered like pretty
quickly
yeah so yeah but like i said all she had
to do was like go to [ __ ]
go to this [ __ ] [ __ ] poor woman
and say yeah this dude is evil you need
to like go
[ __ ] shoot him and she did it
she killed it desperate man she was
desperate desperate for love
like i said i could understand if she
did it for money like hey
i'll give you like for love it's 1957.
yeah
um you know and they're like if like
i'll give you like a hundred thousand
dollars
no that's not what's going on though
they didn't have that kind of money
that's what i'm saying but if somebody
said that i'd think about it i'd be like
it was another time it was another era
that's what i'm saying it's like this
kind of [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
so like i said the only money that she
got like i said was
to buy the gun with and then like joan
didn't even have a plan and so goldeen
goes to the house like with her disguise
i'm like she's supposed to
she shoots peter fabiano like on his
[ __ ]
in his [ __ ] front door yeah and then
she's like she leaves like she runs away
and then she's like oh [ __ ]
like joan didn't tell me what to do to
get rid of the gun like what i should do
with it
so she's just like her first thought was
oh i'm gonna take it to this [ __ ]
um store like a department store called
bullocks
and i'm gonna put it it's in downtown
los angeles i remember those books and
she's like i'm gonna put it in a storage
locker
like why you wouldn't like dump it in a
river or something i don't know because
that would be my first thought
but she paid for it she didn't want to
lose it but she didn't pay for it joan
did
joan paid for it so it's like so like i
said these are not master criminals
and the weird thing about it is that i'm
not sure that
betty the wife was in on this plot
like she didn't get like [ __ ]
indicted or anything like that because
they figured that she didn't know
anything about it this was just
something that
joan who apparently worked with her and
was like
in love with her i guess and was just
like i'm gonna like
tell this other person that i know
to come to your house in a halloween
costume and
kill your husband and then
profit i'm not really sure like what she
thought was gonna happen
you know what i mean like after all of
this [ __ ] was said and done
it just seemed like a really half-baked
plan is what i'm saying
but it's like that was kind of like so
yeah so they find the gun
the cops find the gun because they're
not completely stupid
so they do find the gun and then
basically they're like
well they catch the two women almost
immediately
and they question them and the two women
like gave up the whole [ __ ]
because like i said not master
criminals i don't think they really
thought this through no
is what i'm saying and like i said the
the [ __ ] nowadays is whether his wife
betty um was
you know having an affair with joan did
betty know anything did betty ask
joan hey find somebody to kill my
husband like they didn't really find any
evidence of that
it almost seems like joan took it upon
herself
to take the dude out just so she could
run
off with betty yeah it seems kind of
like that
i don't really know if betty knew
anything about it maybe she did
but they couldn't [ __ ] prove scott's
in there saying he's a half hour behind
and uh he read an interview where dolph
lundgren
said the [ __ ] grace jones that all
she ever wanted to do was go out and
have
orgies and then he said i get behind
that i get
behind that too thank you bro sure yeah
me you grace and the whole orgy thing
imagine that jenny
imagine that [ __ ] yeah sure yeah grace
jones could be there yeah grace would be
up there
if we i mean it'd be nice if we could
like go back in time
yes it's back in time it would have been
better
because then david bowie would you yeah
dave bowie be there everybody else would
be there and like everyone would be
there that we could like get all in
[Laughter]
never mind nobody's old tagging i'm
tagging
jenny and grace jones and [ __ ]
bowie's
[ __ ] me and me and bo are swapping up
i'm [ __ ] high five and bowie
across imagine that jenny then you high
five and bo
bowie well yeah yeah of course of course
yeah of course yeah
this is what this is one of the reasons
i was very sad with david bowie yeah
right yeah
we told that story already we did yeah
me and david bowie's pants
wait what was it just his pants though
just the pants which pants
wait what's your pants
his jared pants oh yeah
you brought that up i did yeah well like
i said you were the one that brought
that [ __ ] up when that movie came out
that was like a big like sexual
awakening for a lot of girls my age
look at that there oh man you [ __ ]
come on
all right on to the next although like i
said i liked that but i
might i had already i'd already had my
sexual awakening with
duran duran and indiana yeah that you
have no okay because that that was my
that was my thing
and also lurch from that kind of like i
know that's weird but you know kind of
like that time me and the go-go's went
on tour
i wish i could where is that [ __ ]
picture i don't know it's funny
i had a picture of you and the gogos
yeah yeah when you were like a baby
not like a baby but they were using me
up those girls
they took me on tour with them yeah yeah
our lips are sealed god damn it go ahead
jenny good
zack says hey it's like i'm at a party
jenny look good with that dude thank you
yeah yeah i do like this wig it's like
it came out nice i put i first put it on
i'm like oh my god it's like so
curly but then like i brushed it and it
was like much better it actually does
kind of look like her hair now
khan says even boy george could join
yeah
boy george should be watching he could
join georgia adam ant
getting it on over in the [ __ ]
quarter yeah yeah
yeah adamant in that [ __ ] indian
outfit
all right with the [ __ ] war paint on
the [ __ ] you know it's weird i know
susie's
in it too oh okay yeah susie's getting
more into this
suzie's in the cluster [ __ ] also
with johnny rod well
and and uh uh [ __ ] um
robert smith from the cure well
before he got fat maybe in 1979 i was
like
no hate yeah yeah he was he wasn't all
that yeah
he was well he was super cute when he
was like super super young
yeah but he has the same problem i have
that like you can't
eat anything without like ballooning out
so
i i sympathize with robert smith
i was kind of like well i was kind of
more like i said
i'm kind of more into
like i said lurch from the addams family
like i was into like uh
andrew eldridge was hot peter murphy was
hot back in the day
back in the day before gore from uh
depeche mode super hot
yeah um you know duran duran like i said
simon was my was my man but nick is good
too
the other three i was kind of like yeah
they're all right
is it well it's weird because i feel
like
in my age contingent i feel like
everyone was kind of more into john
taylor
and i was kind of like he's he's a good
looking dude but i was kind of like
obviously that he was [ __ ] up a lot on
[ __ ] coke and [ __ ] i mean
yeah but that didn't come out i could
see it back then
yeah i could see it back then but he's
tweaking yeah
but it was the same i could spot it back
then
i mean i'm a simon girl like i said
but nick is like really close second
talking all this [ __ ] about these people
man i'm gonna tell you man [ __ ] billy
idol [ __ ] william broad
that [ __ ] was i thought he's
pretty foxy
i thought he was the coolest one i'm not
out of them all just keyless says
leonard nimoy's spock is hot
yes yeah i agree we went on jenny this
is this is why
we talked about that the mirror image
the mirror universal cookie knock it off
all right oh yeah yeah but uh
no yeah nemo nemoy was kind of like
nemoy was the jewish chris reeves
christopher reeves
very similar very similar i think we
were talking about this the other night
because we've been re-watching the
original series
yeah and i noticed yeah i noticed i
don't think they expected that i think
that um you know the chat was like kind
of seen as like the main sex symbol
but then like as the show went on i
think that people were like
surprised at the female um reaction to
spock and like they were like yeah i'm
into that
so it does seem like some episodes in
the third season
they were about all the best [ __ ] which
yeah and like there would be some plot
device
where he would be like oh i'm reverting
back to
like my pre-vulcan right like you know
savagery or romanticism or whatever
let me give a male translation to our
male audience of what was just
said when they came out with [ __ ]
star trek the writers were male
they thought they saw kirk as the main
sex so like obviously they don't know
but the feedback
by the time second sec but definitely by
the time the third season came back
the [ __ ] writers of the writers of
the [ __ ] show had realized that
the female response to [ __ ]
spock was [ __ ]
hard all right the females loved [ __ ]
spock
so they had to write episodes about
spock and women and you see it by the
third
season a lot for men they
identified a lot with kirk but those are
still too but
those are very common alpha male traits
that
spock had the sigma male traits going on
which women respond
to i think better okay
and uh so what they did was is if you
notice there's a couple of those
episodes that are written
around spock very close to [ __ ] they're
basically
romance novel type things
type type plots where spock is the sex
symbol he's resisting the woman he's
resisting it
he loves her but he doesn't want to say
that he does and this is
this is a an aphrodisiac to women well
that is a romance novel true
for a reason right because and like we
said we were talking about the one where
they go to that library and then they go
back in like
in time to like different time periods
and like kirk goes to one time period
where like the [ __ ]
three musketeers live and then [ __ ]
spock and
bones end up in like some arctic
wasteland like
thousands of years ago and what ended up
happening there was that
spock because it was how many thousand
years ago was it five years well it was
like
five thousand years but not in our
history in a in an eighth
planet's history right it wasn't right
it but
they used that as a device to say that
spock was like reverting to a time
era like before vulcan had decided that
we're gonna like overcome our emotions
yeah they were more like romulus right
right
so mariette hartley was there right um
in a little bitty
[ __ ] in that [ __ ] fur outfit with the
phone can you believe we were super
drunk when i was watching this
and he's like oh i know who that is i'm
like yeah i know who that is
and then like 40 minutes in like just
magically i was like
mariette hartley i was like how the [ __ ]
did i pull that out
it was the thighs those thighs got you
did was it yeah i remember
i just remembered her name like just i
don't know how i remembered that because
that's how my brain works
but so him like falling in love with
mariette hartley's character i can't
remember what her character name was on
the show
but that's like a popular like romance
novel trope
is that a dude like spock who
ostensibly cannot feel any emotions or
doesn't
show any outward emotions and you
are the one woman breaking that up bring
that [ __ ] out
that is very that is like catnip yeah so
they started writing
stories about the about that because
you're special
right yeah exactly women just like to be
special exactly
exactly and i gotta give [ __ ] props
to namoy okay
namoy like i said that's that's that's
the jewish christopher reeves
you know what i mean [ __ ] kurt
kirk okay [ __ ] shatner william
shatner's jewish too
but i think he was more adopted
genetically he just looks like a [ __ ]
i think he just he converted
yeah yeah or his or some of his
ancestors converted
nemoy looks jewish but that's that's
like [ __ ] high quality
jewish genetics you know what i mean
[ __ ] if you go back
to muay was a beautiful that's that
that's jewish
jewish male sexuality at the [ __ ]
highest
of the highest order uh sexy the women
[ __ ] loved him
just well like i said he had unusual
features that worked
that's what i'm saying right yeah like i
i feel like women in general and like i
said i would never
speak for every woman because i'm that
[ __ ] right there yeah
yeah but he had like a really like if
you have like really
interesting features that's almost
better than just being like generically
good luck
because if you're generically good
looking then you're very forgettable
i'm just saying in general men they're
going to relate to [ __ ] kirk
women they're about to spot they're just
saying well and spock's
personality is very similar to my
personality and so it's like
every time we watch the original series
he laughs at me because it's like every
time somebody like gives spock some [ __ ]
i'm
like stop picking on spock he's right
god damn it he's always right you know
what i mean some people are just getting
the notifications now that the show was
on
they're telling my spock how good the
[ __ ] spock was spock was cool
collected
alien energy he's never been very little
oh yeah
and like i said i i i cultivate my own
spotness
in my own life yeah that's like i said
he's very similar a lot
she's very similar to my own personality
you gotta understand something
a lot of [ __ ] has been lost over the
decades
spock is a jewish character very much so
okay namoy wrote that
that that started off as a very generic
i mean
that character it started off very very
[ __ ] generic
and then namoy took took what he knew
what he knew about judaism and being a
being a jew being an
outsider being an outsider inside the
american system and he [ __ ]
he made that character it is a jewish
character
and that's a [ __ ] badass character
and it's badass because of nemoy
really leonard nimoy knew how
one he knew how to act he knew how to
manipulate the energy and the gifts that
he was given
and he took the whole outsider and other
thing
and made that into a sci-fi that's what
i mean he owned it that [ __ ]
right you know right right yeah and the
thing is is that spock was [ __ ] cool
it wasn't nerdy he's very cool and um
well like i said i just got to show you
how to get how gifted [ __ ] namoy was
yeah
he was able to put across someone who
essentially was always right um he was
in a lot of ways what nowadays you would
say he was like a nerdy character
because he knew everything alpha nerd
but he could still come across
as like cool because he always knew what
was going on he was always correct
everybody looked to him for you know
guidance because he was the one that
knew what was going on
i'mma counter that he wasn't always
correct well
mostly you had he was good at certain
things
he was very proficient he was very
proficient at logic and all these other
skills
there were some episodes that showed the
limitations of that like when the
galileo
crashed he's doing he's dealing with
emotion and he's dealing with other
people he wasn't good at that
that was the good thing about the star
trek the original series one
it was theater but it was also
philosophy
and it reflected reality it wasn't
a [ __ ] version of [ __ ]
of ideology it was that's the way things
really are
but we're gonna tell you this tale in a
mythological
sci-fi format to teach you a lesson
and uh yeah man no you go to [ __ ] if
you want to [ __ ] learn some [ __ ]
you go to the original series
then you watch the movies and you see
star trek continues free
on [ __ ] youtube because [ __ ] star
trek continues is also like
the final to me it's the final [ __ ]
um season of the original series and it
all just
kind of falls into place some people say
deep space nine d space nine was [ __ ]
very cool with cisco and everything
wait i don't think i saw you've seen
that voyager was good
do you [ __ ] next generations had a
lot of good episodes i liked that
but really you know i [ __ ] liked
enterprise with [ __ ] archer
and shrand he loves enterprises i love
enterprise shrand [ __ ]
well jeffrey cohen jeffrey combs was
[ __ ] strange
well strand was the alien
version of [ __ ] general patton i
[ __ ] love shran
shran was a good character that was back
when they could write cool stories they
don't have the talent now
we'll see it's just like everything else
it's a cycle
it will come back okay it will come back
now star trek
star trek discovery that they have now
[ __ ] right but that doesn't mean that
it'll come back across the board that
there are no good writers the best
sci-fi
going right now today would be
mandalorian
when it comes to sci-fi writing
mandalorian
uh season one [ __ ] somebody sent it
to me on blu-ray i [ __ ] loved it
i don't have season two yet but from
what i'm hearing season two is supposed
to be awesome didn't that just start
it just started if anybody has season
two
send it to me i ain't giving disney
although uh well i'm telling you right
now i
just um i just got hulu because it was
cheap
yeah um there's a disney plus add-on
is it i don't know i don't know how much
more it is so if you want me to do that
but hulu has a bunch of [ __ ] that
i wanted to see that the best sci-fi
today i watched books of blood that
clive barker
from what i've seen right now the best
sci-fi new sci-fi
going is mandalorian but if you want
traditional sci-fi
with good [ __ ] lessons that will
[ __ ] help you in life and help
explain [ __ ] is that's the original
series
well i feel like the original series in
a lot of ways was like really ahead of
its time
yeah i mean in its attitudes yeah and
it's kind of like the best
it's just very like [ __ ] humanistic
yeah you know that's what i like about
it it's just kind of like
you had all these sci-fi writers like
writing for the show
and from you know it it was just like a
very
everything was very like logically come
to you it's like everything was very
like what are we gonna do about this
problem
and it's just like i really really like
the way the writing went on the original
series
like i don't think i've seen a lot of
the i saw enterprise because you showed
me that which was good
um i've seen some of the ones with
picard i haven't seen the new picard
but what's wrong everybody says the new
card is not good
the writings none of that's going to
survive people are talking about star
trek in the [ __ ]
comments now yeah
the origin okay the thing with [ __ ]
enterprise is that enterprise had a weak
start
it took a couple seasons once europe
once you were there
what uh [ __ ] with like the uh
uh [ __ ] when the when the [ __ ] time
war started i thought
i thought it got a lot better that was
around halfway through season two
i thought it was really good then but
there's just something about
the original series deep space nine was
good like i said
next generation it had some really good
episodes it had some good [ __ ] about the
borg and everything
yeah i liked those but there was
something about next generation is that
sometimes it got kind of
soapy you know what i mean that was i
well i feel like that's the danger of
every show
that hap well because here's the thing
you can't have
[ __ ] super action happening like
every second
you're gonna have to have like some
human drama because you complained about
this about the walking dead too like
yeah
um but i feel like every show does that
after a time because you kind of have to
yeah
because people don't like give a [ __ ]
about the characters or don't give a
[ __ ] about the relationships between the
characters it's like like i said you
can't have like [ __ ]
ninjas fighting dinosaurs in every
single episode
because of the restroom you know yeah so
you know what
i don't know he puts his he puts his
hand like right where my
mouse is this is like
all right while he's gone i'm gonna talk
about some more murders
so you said disney plus was like another
six bucks
um i don't know like i feel like i
really
like i don't know why just like
yesterday i was kind of like you know
what
i'm gonna like get hulu even though i
already paid for netflix i already
played
pay for shutter but then i was like you
know what i feel like maybe i should pay
for
hulu as well because it's kind of cheap
and it has like a bunch of movies that
neither of those have so
i just paid for that and like this
morning while i was like getting ready
for the halloween show i actually
watched
books of blood which i guess was a hulu
original
like thing like an adaptation of like
the climb barker thing
which was pretty good i mean it was
gory and stuff and it was all right
but you know they i just like went
through their [ __ ] and it's like they
had a lot of stuff that
uh neither netflix nor shutter had so i
was like i was like all right
but i don't know i don't know if i want
to play pay another six dollars for like
the
disney plus thing although i do love the
mandalorian so
i don't know i'll think about it but
we'll see how it goes
all right so let's talk about another
murder now this one i'm going to tell
you right now
kind of a bummer because a little kid
this happened in 1973
when i was one year old now this was a
little girl named lisa french
she was nine years old
now halloween 1973 comes along
and she actually wants to dress as a
butterfly
but because they're in fond du lac
wisconsin it's cold as [ __ ] on halloween
which i have never experienced because
i'm in florida
and it's always like swamp ass season
pretty much
uh it's always hot here on halloween but
up there it's cold
so her mom was just kind of like yeah
you can't be a butterfly
because it's too cold out so why don't
you like find another costume
like that's warmer so
lisa decides she's gonna dress like a
hobo because
that's kind of what you do when you
can't dress as something else
so she has some dinner and then she gets
all excited about trick-or-treating like
we all did back in the 70s
and she goes out of the door and starts
trick-or-treating now
what she was supposed to do was she was
supposed to go
and like meet up with a friend of hers
and they were supposed to go to this
place called
the pumpkin place and i guess like even
back in the early 70s i don't remember
this [ __ ]
but what are you looking at me what am i
looking at okay i thought you were
looking at something like someone was
still like chasing you or something
right like what are you looking at well
he's like looking at the door like
someone's gonna chase him in here
no not at all where is pookie by the way
i don't know where she is
i meant to like make her a witch i got
70 people on here watching already what
yeah yeah see what everybody's saying go
ahead
okay so like i said this one's kind of a
bummer so you know because it's a little
girl
so lisa's out dressed like a hobo
so she's supposed to like meet her
friend and they're supposed to go to
this place called the pumpkin place
now some of the parents had like put
together this kind of like
[ __ ] even back in the 70s like for the
kids to hang out in i'm gonna find call
the pumpkin place there he goes oh
cookies in
the top uh apartment oh okay she's so
she's it
she's sleeping at this time of it's
ridiculous
holy crap sun's just going down which
means we're probably gonna have
trick-or-treaters here at a bit well you
think that like the little ones the
little ones always come before
no talent we'll see how there's no tail
like i said if they don't come i'm
eating all that [ __ ] candy
we got a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of candy we
did we got a huge bag of sands
i bought the high cal i bought that high
quality candy
we'll get the just in case we had to eat
it all get the good [ __ ]
get the snickers snickers and milky way
and twix
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
three musketeers yeah don't get the like
[ __ ] smarties no i got the good [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
we live in a [ __ ] high class
neighborhood we're gonna get the [ __ ]
good [ __ ]
gonna get the good [ __ ] hold on give me
my hand
put that in there got a hand on my
shoulders guiding me
is it okay okay but yeah so
all right so are you [ __ ] her are you
[ __ ] here
wait who are you [ __ ] this is getting
weird yeah okay all right yeah
okay now like yeah unattached hands
are like no yeah they're coming in here
getting at you that
oh my goodness oh my goodness
yeah this [ __ ] dress y'all yeah
so well the the ticker tapes in front of
them
i'm glad yeah well because here's the
thing what are you doing
my hands running away oh good i got it
if you guys have seen fright night you
guys know that like the dress she wore
when she got like vampirized or whatever
was
very much like the marilyn monroe dress
so
other than like it had like a big like
[ __ ] white waistband
but i figured that wouldn't show so i
just bought like a [ __ ]
marilyn monroe dress because it's a
halter it's like it looks
close enough um
also this dress like super see-through
so i had to buy a slip
also i had to buy one of those weird
like stick-on bras because
i don't have any white bras yeah i'm
telling you man that [ __ ] can't support
those [ __ ] mountains
that's what i'm saying so i got like one
of the stick on bras and i put it on
earlier i'm like
is this even that's 20 pounds of titty
right there [ __ ] there's no way
it's like there's a huge i was so
annoyed
so annoyed like he lost
we're gonna sell videos he loves it but
i'm just kind of like
really really
i'm putting the shade like oh it's
supposed to like push it up yeah that's
not
no not with that not with those massive
[ __ ] mouths
they're so heavy that's [ __ ] pouring
those [ __ ] so
so it's kind of like it didn't work out
so much but i was just kind of like well
at least i will put the white dress on
and i will be confident that no one will
like
see anything through the [ __ ] so
take your ass to vegas make some big
bucks with you
okay
[Laughter]
crazy he is constantly trying to pimp me
out
no no no no no don't say that people
might believe it
i try to pimp out my [ __ ] dudes that
i know
i'm just gonna like a little mad i try
to tip out matt all the time
then matt you're sitting on a gold mine
bro
take your ass up to vegas put you in the
[ __ ] stable with the rest of my mares
you're going to make she has a stable
with me and they'll stable the mares
most of them are boys
matt frickin who else is in my stable
matt you just saw him out the other day
yeah [ __ ]
then i talked to him drunkenly about
yeah
dude i talked to him drunkenly that well
he was he was getting
into voice acting yeah yeah and i was
kind of like oh man i've just gotten
into like
you know doing all the [ __ ] audio
books and [ __ ] and i was so excited
about doing my legend of sleepy hollow
[ __ ]
for halloween because i was just kind of
like oh man i love the story and i was
like so happy to like
[ __ ] read it even though other people
have read it but i was kind of like i'm
getting into it so we were like we were
super drunk and we were like talking
well
i was drunk i don't know what he was on
because
um he he likes some uh substances
yes you know so i don't ever know what
he's on when i see him
but you know he's a he's a nice dude
though
they're telling me to drink up [ __ ] no
no i'm trying to stay out of control bro
ooh this bloody mary is delicious though
yeah how much how much you got left
a lot okay good i'm only in the second
okay
all right i mean we're already at two
hours yeah
we need to get this show [ __ ] done
sometime today well we will
sometime sometime but it's halloween
yeah i think they're gonna start
knocking on the door here in a minute
it's halloween
all right i don't know man it's pandemic
yeah
i don't know if people are gonna be like
knocking on the door or no
we'll see we have like lights out yeah
we have like you know those [ __ ] the
lights
yeah the projector lights we have ghosts
and we have like white ghosts so we have
purple bats
yeah we have all that on the front
because we're lazy
yeah what are you looking at making sure
the [ __ ] pumpkin's there
i've been covering up the pumpkin i need
to come back here
i spent a lot of time carving yeah see
how small i get it
see i smell like it let me get small
back here
can you guys still hear me probably
cause i'm more free to move back here
you can go back to just yell when you
talk can you guys hear me go ahead give
me give me a sound check
zach says it's funny to see me play with
my hair in a feminine way
well i have a lot of hair but because i
am a
girl i am a no [ __ ] person so it's
like i usually i have very long very
thick hair so i usually like pull it all
back because i don't
i don't really have the patience to like
[ __ ] with it normally
so having this wig on is very weird
because it's like i'm not used to like
having hair right here
that i have to move yeah
oracle says we can hear you okay good
good good all right
all right so like i said here's this
poor nine-year-old girl she's dressed
like a hobo
she's going out trick-or-treating now
she's supposed to go to this place
called the pumpkin place
which all the parents had kind of like
put together it was like a safe space
whatever back in 1973. um you're all
supposed to go there
now she's supposed to go there but she
goes there and the friend that she's
supposed to meet there
had like actually gotten into trouble
and had gotten
uh you know she wasn't allowed to go out
she got grounded
so lisa was like okay well [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna go out by myself
because i'm nine that's just what i do
now she goes to
one house it's fine she goes to another
house that's fine now she goes to the
third house
and not so fine
so she only got to like [ __ ] two
houses that night right
the third house she goes to belongs to a
dude
named gerald miles turn junior
now she knew this dude
because this dude used to live in the
other half of a duplex
where her family used to live so
they were like friendly so she didn't
think anything about it like i said she
goes to the first couple houses she gets
candy she goes to this house she's like
hey gerald what's up
and yeah that's
like how it ends up [ __ ] so
apparently they were like friends
so he like is like hey
why don't you come inside and she didn't
think anything of it because she knew
him
he was their neighbor previously so she
didn't think anything was wrong
now what ends up happening though is
that
she's like okay fine i'll come inside
[ __ ] gerald
takes her into a back bedroom and then
rapes her damn she's
nine yeah she's nine
and then or so he says oh well
i was raping her and suddenly um
she wasn't breathing no and she killed
and she fought back
and killed her yeah i kind of feel like
that's what happened to you
but you know what i mean that's kind of
like
yeah so he said oh she's not breathing i
tried to resuscitate her
um my girlfriend came home it was this
thing
and um so he put evidently
his girlfriend comes home while he's in
the middle of this
situation and he puts
socks on his hands i guess
he didn't have any gloves and he moves
lisa's body which at this point i don't
know if she's dead or if she's like
i don't know but he like moves her to
the master bathroom
he's like yeah i'll like deal with that
[ __ ] later on
so his girlfriend comes home he comes
out like he's in a bathrobe
and he's like yeah i don't feel so good
right now
like but the girlfriend said that while
she was there
she's like man he was acting really
weird like he kept going back in the
bedroom like there was something
in there like that he needed to check on
and she thought that was really weird
back there molesting all that dead body
right or like checking on it
and it's like oh my god this is like
[ __ ] horrifying
so like the girlfriend thought it was
weird but like not weird enough to like
call the cops because like
you know why would you you wouldn't
think your [ __ ] boyfriend was doing
this kind of [ __ ]
so the girlfriend is like okay whatever
man and then she goes to her
mother's house it's halloween night you
know shit's going on
so after she leaves
gerald puts [ __ ] lisa's body
because apparently she's dead now he
puts her in a trash bag
and all her all of her stuff like all
her bag and everything
he puts in trash bags and then he like
drives it out of town
a couple of miles and dumps them in a
field
now meanwhile lisa's parents
obviously are just kind of like okay
well she was supposed to be
back by seven o'clock
because they were supposed to go do that
thing with the friend and it's like
that didn't happen and you know so she
didn't come back by seven
so the mom is like starting to freak out
as you would
and then three more hours go by
10 o'clock it's like lisa is still not
home
and the mom flips out she calls the cops
everybody like the neighborhood
all they all come out to like look for
this little girl
they all put like and they can't find
her so they're all like putting [ __ ]
time then the windows
[ __ ] like that they call the cops cops
start a search party
the cops search all night they can't
find anything
they said that like 5 000 people
joined this [ __ ] search looking for
this little girl
they call in the national guard they
call in [ __ ]
like dudes that owned like planes and
[ __ ]
call in for this stuff they're all like
looking through the [ __ ]
they go through all the bodies of water
in the area
they're looking everywhere for this
little girl they do like [ __ ]
flyers 6 000 flyers everywhere
now later there's this
farmer and he's driving around in his
tractor like you do on a farm
and he finds two garbage bags on his
property
and he's like huh what are these doing
here so he opens them up
and guess what there's a little ghost
body in there
yep so damn
yeah sometimes well like i said it's a
halloween show it's kind of
yeah it's kind of hard i'm listening to
these [ __ ] in the comments saying
what are they saying i keep playing with
my hair
and that this is the hair i had when i
was in the fifth grade [ __ ] you [ __ ]
it's a wig man isn't he here it's a wig
it's just itching
[ __ ] itches man i kind of like my wig
actually
itches it's kind of it's like having a
[ __ ] rug on your head
a 70s shag rug like i said i'm not used
to having hair this close to my face
because i always used to like
because i have you know i have
very long hair and it's very it's like
baby hair but it's also there's a lot of
it
yeah it [ __ ] falls out constantly
yeah so it's kind of every time i brush
it every time i wash it every time it's
like there's
big chunks of it there's like you have
to pull like chunks of it out of the
[ __ ] shower drain yeah
it's like all over the [ __ ] bathroom
floor every time i brush it because it
always like falls out
yeah so it's kind of like there's just
hair all over this [ __ ] house
that's my hair well i gotta vacuum it up
it's not my open house all the time
i clean it up well i know but like i
said it's a pain of dance
so but for that reason
i usually keep it like all pulled back
because
it's a pain i don't want it like in my
face all the time because it's always
like
so it's very weird to have this to have
curly hair like
in my face my natural hair will not curl
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hair bro let's get along with you
yeah
it's fake hair so
yeah it's a hair system it's a hair
system yeah
so okay at this point
so the girls found dead right
farmer found her in the field now
they had actually started questioning
gerald turner
the day after um lisa had been reported
missing just because
he was a neighbor of theirs formerly and
like he had known her
so they were kind of questioning
everybody
um now they also knew that because
she had only been to two houses before
she disappeared that obviously
somebody along the route um had to
know what happened to her so
the two people they questioned the two
people that had um
that she had gone to their houses
previously and they were just like yeah
she came here she got candy it was all
fine she took off
so after that point like the third house
they're like okay well no one's seeing
her after this point so
something had to have happened at this
stage
so they questioned gerald turner he's
like what i don't know anything like i
just gave her candy and she took off or
whatever
um but they didn't buy that which
they shouldn't and uh so they continued
questioning him they questioned him for
[ __ ]
nine months they kept bringing him in
they kept questioning him [ __ ] like that
and finally after nine months he broke
down
and confessed that he had killed her
um so during the trial
the medical examiner said that lisa
french had actually
died of asphyxiation
she wasn't smothered she wasn't
strangled she wasn't anything like that
it appeared that she had died during the
course
of the sexual assault
so it does appear that this dude i don't
know if he like intended to kill her
but he was for sure raping her which
he intended to rape her and not tell her
if you're intending to rape someone and
she resisted so he killed her
that's what happened i kind of feel like
that's what happened to him like he's
kind of like oh
like well i was raping her it was an
accident it's like
no that doesn't make it any better that
doesn't mean by that i got a bridge to
sell you doesn't make any better yeah
because if you're raping her then
already yeah you've already prison
forever right it's she's nine
come on he's sorry because i'm a rapid
well like i said she used to live in the
other side of the duplex like so they
were like neighbors previously
yes so he had probably been thinking
about that [ __ ] for like forever
which we saw her it was a few years
later and he's like she's like that
he's like that looks pretty good i'm
gonna rape that girl oh she's nine
yeah yeah she's grown up now i'm gonna
get her
and then she fought back and it wasn't
the way he imagined it so he killed her
because she probably was like i'm going
to tell ya what i mean and he's like oh
you're going to tell me i'm going to
kill you then
that's probably what she did i'm going
to tell
i hope she did i mean well no she
couldn't tell she was dead
i know but it's like she [ __ ] fought
him i hope she [ __ ] hurt him
she started fighting back and she said
i'm gonna tell everybody i'm gonna tell
you better let me go and
he's like oh if you're gonna tell it i
gotta kill you
that's what happened because her mind
didn't jump to that
that he would kill her because she was
going to i mean
i i kind of like i when i should have
said i wouldn't tell anybody and then he
lets her go and then she goes and tells
well that's what i mean it's like i was
trying to
like like place myself back into it like
when i was nine
yeah and it's like i don't know it kind
of scares me because it's like
i'll think an adult and that's that's
what i mean that's what like freaks me
out about that [ __ ]
because it's like when i was not i can't
even remember when i was nine but it's
like i don't think i think i would have
just went along with whatever an adult
told me to do
yeah well maybe something like that you
would although something like
that i'd be like yeah no you better let
me go i'm gonna [ __ ] tell on you i'm
gonna tell on you
but you but you're a kid you don't
realize that he's gonna that if you say
that he kills you
i kind of feel like as a nine-year-old
i'm and i'm projecting
back like to the from you know the way i
was later
i think that when i was not if somebody
had done that to me i think i would have
been
like yeah i won't tell anybody and then
like as soon as he was gone i would have
told adam there's adults that make the
same everybody
there's adults that make the same
[ __ ]
dumb ass mistakes i saw a [ __ ]
security video
a [ __ ] robbery going down in brazil
because all the [ __ ] good ones are
going down in brazil
some guys jump off a [ __ ] motorcycle
with guns
they're robbing the place okay somebody
reaches and grabs their
phone to take a [ __ ] picture of the
robbery what do they do
blow his [ __ ] head off
think about it yeah
what do you mean yeah they [ __ ]
a robbery is going on what does the dude
do
grab his phone his cell phone and try to
videotape it they kill him
well unless you're in a in a place where
they can't see you
i would not no no no no he was just in a
[ __ ] i would not advise him
yeah you know it's just he thinks none
of his mind
that because he can get them on camera
that they will stop
doing what they were doing that's yeah
that's an idiotic [ __ ] concept well
dudes had [ __ ] guns
look it's it's the 21st century if
you're filming somebody doing something
they're obviously not ashamed of it
so it's like filming them is not going
to shame them
into stopping to me no they killed him
because they'll just
yeah and that they're obviously proud of
it
that's the same thing well that's the
same thing as a motel
don't tell them that you're gonna tell
you're talking about do that [ __ ] on the
download yeah
all right i'm gonna tell that's what i'm
saying i'll find kill you
i'm more a go along with the person
until you're out of danger right then
[ __ ] them right
right i'm more of that kind of i
couldn't believe it i mean they're
robbing the [ __ ] gas station and the
dude pulls out his phone
and tries to stop them by [ __ ]
recorded they just kill him
yeah that's just which like i said
that's not
not blaming the victim i'm just saying
that i'm on
go ahead that is not something that you
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and blame the
victim
you stupid [ __ ]
i would never do that they'll kill you
well yeah i'm not going to film some
like crime going on right now like hey
look at this [ __ ]
so let that be a lesson to you people
out there
okay don't film crimes in progress i've
seen the [ __ ] crimes
if they're gonna do the crime they're
doing the crime they might as well
add another crime yeah they don't give a
[ __ ] you might as well [ __ ]
no no if
if they're already committing the crime
your camera is not going to [ __ ] help
you they'll [ __ ] kill you
okay yeah you're like look i'm feeling
what are you doing that they're like
right just let them go
let them leave let them head here like i
said film it but film it on the down low
well they've been like leaving already
filming at maybe when they're on the
motorcycles trying to pull away
but they were right there he [ __ ]
pulled out the camera to film them to
try to stop him and they just [ __ ]
turned around and shot him right in the
[ __ ] head
and he hit the ground like a sack of
[ __ ] i mean you know what i mean you
a camera is not a gun it just didn't
well and like i said anyone that's gonna
do that kind of crime is not gonna be
shamed no by by that damn camera
right so like i said if you're going to
film like film it by all means but you
can get away with it keep it on the
download
right and then report it later yeah well
that's all i'm saying and that's kind of
what i'm doing from a safe distance
that's what i'm saying that's what i
advocate i advocate
just going along with [ __ ] and then just
be like yeah
i'm not gonna report [ __ ] until you're
like safe and then you're like i'm
reporting
all the [ __ ] you were going to prison
like you know what i mean just get your
ass out of danger
that's all i'm saying but yeah so
this um piece of [ __ ] this douchebag
this [ __ ] whatever you wanted this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wobble whatever you want to call it
so he has this little girl that he had
lived next door to
for a very long time and apparently had
been like watching her
for whatever reason and then finally
he's like yay she's coming to my house
trick-or-treating
hey come in here and she didn't think
anything of it because she knew him
and then she comes in here and he rapes
her
and then he's like oh i accidentally
killed her in the course of like [ __ ]
which i don't [ __ ] believe
i feel like she was raping her and she's
like yeah [ __ ] not
cool and he was like okay well
and then killed her so yeah
so it took them like nine [ __ ] months
of questioning
but finally finally they got him to
confess
now sadly the jury only found him guilty
of second-degree murder
because i guess it wasn't premeditated
okay it wasn't premeditated so second
degree murder
they also got him on enticing a child
for immoral purposes
which was a thing um acts of sexual
perversion
because you know pedophile they went
easy on this dude
um yeah now
you don't see a nine-year-old girl again
well i'm gonna get that
that's what i mean that seems like
that's a
big red flag that should that that
should be death penalty
nine years old that should be death
penalty
i'm not arguing with you on that just
because that's death penalty [ __ ]
because that's like some [ __ ] normal
people no one sees
no one normal no no one normally he's a
nine year old girl
yeah it's like oops oops oh my god oh oh
oh i accidentally that's yeah that does
not happen
that does not happen unless you were
already a garbage
person yeah to start with i'm just
saying
that dude had that dude there had a
[ __ ]
had a very lenient judge had there been
me
that mother that [ __ ] would be on death
row
you would think that's serial killer
[ __ ] what are you talking about that's
what i mean
i read about these [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day that is a red
flag red flag so yeah guilty second
degree murder enticing a child for
immoral purposes
acts of sexual perversion because like i
said pedophile
now one of the um
psychologists at the uh correctional
institute where he was
taken has said and i quote
he has a cold disregard for people
mainly females
i.e women um he does not have
conscience control to inhibit his
impulses for pleasure and to confront
to confront to society's laws confront
what you mean that's what i mean i i
don't think that's the word you wanted
to use dude i think
you meant conform to performances but
okay um
to confront to society's laws yeah but
yeah so
i don't know is that really is that
really an excuse
i feel like no no um
he felt uh the judge said he seemed to
feel no remorse for the crime
so yay no um he was actually paroled he
served
17 years and was paroled in 1992
he went to live at a halfway
now house paroled yeah
i mean he was 72 years old well he was
uh he'd been in prison for 17 years
and he was paroled in 1992. he was put
in 1973.
[ __ ] needed to die let me go to the
restroom hold on probably and i gotta
check the front door
yeah make sure there's no bring us some
candy
so he goes to live to halfway house now
understandably when he gets let out of
parole in 1992
um the community is like not having it
which
you know obviously um
fond du lac wisconsin there's kind of
like a bunch of them got together and
they're like we are going to
uh file a civil lawsuit against the
government for releasing him
into you know onto the streets
so they basically said you guys like
[ __ ] up and we don't want this dude
like running around
so their lawsuit actually worked
uh turner was actually put back in
prison
because the state said yeah we [ __ ] up
we shouldn't let that dude out
so they put him back in prison for a
little while
but then he was like he was gonna be let
out in 1994
but at that point they're like well
1994 it's like maybe we should put him
in a mental institution because
in some ways like mental institution is
good because it's like it's treatment
and everything
but mental institution is always
kind of a thing where they put people
like well we don't have
we don't know when we're going to let
them out
so it's kind of like we don't have like
a the end of the sentence where we had
to let them out so
that's kind of like what happened in
this situation so
they put him in a mental institution
so 1998 gerald turner
actually goes to court again now
he's saying at this point look i'm not a
sexual predator i've been in like
you know custody for this many years um
i shouldn't be in this mental
institution whatever
everything is fine and at this point in
1998 a jury says
okay that's cool and they let him out
now they let him out
and he went to a halfway house however
only a few years later
um you know he's still kind of on parole
he's still kind of being
uh watched or whatever oh my goodness
yeah
i got some candy you brought me some
homemade oh my goodness
look at that [ __ ] look at look at the
bounty
of halloween candy we have not had any i
haven't heard the doorbell no it hasn't
nobody's but nobody showed up
well i kind of thought that might happen
so
so like i said so he's like we're gonna
get all the candy
that's all right by me so he's [ __ ]
you
[Laughter]
look at you with your [ __ ] shirt you
don't even [ __ ] realize that it's
like
no it's supposed to be like but that's
why it wasn't a movie
this way it wasn't a movie it's not her
shirt
it's an overall yeah it's like he got
the dickies
like over like the jumpsuit is exactly
what he was it's a whole jumpsuit
that's what his prison uniform was
mm-hmm yeah
like i gotta admire like you went all
out yeah
i was impressed i looked at what he was
wearing i got it
i was impressed and this is probably his
fake hand
his fake hand was his own hand with a
glove on it
well it wasn't his own hand it was a
robot hand it was supposed to be but
that's not what it was it was his own
hand
well done yeah but
in the universe of the movie yeah it was
like a robot
yeah it wasn't really robot it was a
prosthetic a prosthetic hand
they could like do and you could put it
out and it would like
the thing that killed me about that
movie was that
they gave him a prosthetic hand which
was like
several times more powerful than a human
hand they could like crush a person's
neck
yeah like in there like i'm not sure
they would do that
in real life it was just levers it was
on a rubber
it was on a [ __ ] leather strap so
it's like if you
it's like we're not saying to do this
but it's like if you wanted to
theoretically yeah you could take this
fake hand
and just like crush someone's windpipe
very very easily and he's just like
he was strong but he couldn't he
couldn't draw he couldn't draw cartoons
with it
that's a problem he could crush your ass
with it though
[Laughter]
which was the next best thing yeah but
yeah
these are good look at all this
look at this bounty of candy what time
is it
it's 7 20. okay well i feel like little
kids would have come to the house by now
we haven't had a single doorbell
well like i said it's pandemic
i feel like people are like going to do
other things during halloween so it's
like they might not be trick-or-treating
which is okay with me because i'm just
gonna eat all this [ __ ]
so yeah 1998 this douche
michael's asking if i shave or am i
naturally hairdos
michael you get no one is naturally
hairy are you gay bro
you into the male body no one is
naturally hairless
i'm a man about fastidious
[ __ ] grooming i groom my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm like like an ancient roman
i'll shave everything shave and shrimp
then when you're presentable porn star
style
you did you done oh okay of course i'm
done i need a snicker
he's a snicker man that's all you need
he is like as long as i've known him
he has shaved everything
yeah but i don't really like grow a
whole lot of body hair i'm civilized
but i don't have that's that's one of
the things that i like because i feel
like there's this double standard where
i don't have those monkey genetics
well i feel like there's a double
standard where dudes want
women to shave everything yeah
but they're not willing yeah they look
like [ __ ] they look like [ __ ]
but there's like yeah that's what i mean
they'll be like there's [ __ ] hair all
over the chest and they're [ __ ] junk
and everything it's like i don't wanna
put that in my mouth come on
i'm a gentleman that's what i mean so i
so i like that about you that you are
willing to go the extra mile yeah
it's like you do like what women are
expected to do always
that's why i have such a long line of
beautiful women in my [ __ ] past i got
pictures to prove even jenny knows
i do i got [ __ ] nothing but beautiful
women
your last one i'm the last one
[Laughter]
he's throwing all the garbage up in here
yeah i'm putting it over there
yeah so what happened the ultimate one
that's right i'm the only one i'm the
ultimate woman that's right ma'am yeah
i am kind of i always kind of felt i i
always kind of felt like myself
like like that yeah you the ultimate one
well because i felt like i was the
ultimate
um no i'm like i'm like the
the exact middle ground between the best
feminine qualities and the best
masculine qualities oh you got masculine
qualities
hey i didn't know that tell me all your
logic
logic my love of horror movies all that
kind of stuff
which for a long time was considered
very masculine okay
so yeah right yeah you said okay
yeah other people might disagree
but i always kind of like felt like i
was kind of like the perfect like
balance between the two i don't know
maybe i'm weird maybe
maybe i'm not like that
i would like to eat more candy but i
gotta like [ __ ] there's more right
there
i gotta do well i know but i gotta do
this [ __ ] show okay go ahead
so this um do chat
douche yeah he lives in halfway
house now because he's still on parole
they have to like go and check his [ __ ]
for like parole fight
violations or whatnot so they do a
um a check of his computer in 2003
and not surprisingly his computer
in 2003 was full of like porn
now it wasn't necessarily
child porn but any kind of porn was
a parole violation so
um he gets sent back to jail
now at this stage i believe the last
time i looked up the [ __ ]
um he is being considered for pearl
again but i feel like
no one's really like all that excited
about letting him out
because you see what happens when that
happens
so you know all right so
the next case we're going to talk about
is the very famous
man who killed halloween that's what
they call him
because he's the dude that was behind
all the urban legends oh my god i can't
even compete with this
i can't compete with this do you even
have like underwear
on under that stuff yeah okay
i was kind of afraid he was gonna like
unzip some stuff and like some [ __ ]
the zipper's all [ __ ] up some [ __ ]
dude got it now i got it
i got it okay it was open on both sides
[ __ ] dick was going to pop out
i don't know no i got underwear on what
time
tila says when you guys eat candy you
have to tell us what it is
mostly it's been we got the big thing at
sam's
oh hey there's still candy in that three
musketeers
snickers twix snickers and twix and
milky way
the four food groups all four food
groups
i like it yeah that's the real [ __ ]
there man
and cupcakes are the fifth yeah we got
those two got two more
probably we got later we got more
cupcakes waiting
wow i guess not three musketeers
three musketeers are better when they're
frozen
they are yeah i'm like into i like the
snickers i like the twix
you know what i mean yeah all right so
we're going to talk about this [ __ ]
douchebag
who inspired all the urban legends you
know urban legends like when you were
growing up
about some [ __ ] is gonna like put
poison in your candy or put like razor
blades in your apples or whatever
this dude is the reason that all that
happened
and he was related to the kid he killed
so
here we go this is ronald clark o'brien
this happened in 1974 when jenny was two
years old
he is uh nicknamed the candyman and the
man who killed halloween
now what happened we're on story three
this is story three and how many we have
four four
okay you're good like i said i'm doing
them chronologically trying to get the
[ __ ] time right let me see what we
got going on
7 27 it's still early yeah it's like
yeah you guys you guys all good out
there you're good you're
drinking bloody marys yeah three hour
shows all right with you guys
all right wait we're at two and a half
hours it's good though it's
gonna be a four-hour show okay i'm like
not concerned about it
i'm just playing with my wig because i'm
not used to having this hair over here
okay so here's this dude
it makes me think about taking his food
out for [ __ ] um
to thaw it what kind of food
i don't know i got well [ __ ] i got all
kinds of fresh stuff i got fresh
beef i got fresh chicken he went to
sam's yesterday he's very excited
yeah i'll make something oh but you know
what we got the
uh we got all those [ __ ] hat frozen
hamburger patties we have to use up and
i have the uh
hamburger buns and stuff we gotta just
have a quick hamburger
you think i'll [ __ ] thaw some of
those patties
sure okay let me throw some patties of
course he's gonna do that right now let
me go put them out
okay go ahead so
like i said
we're talking about the man who killed
halloween
so this is a dude
he has a wife
her name's deneen okay
they live in deer park texas they have
two children
timothy their son and they have a
daughter named elizabeth
now this dude mr o'brien
he was an optician and he worked at
texas state optical in sharpstown
houston
also much like btk
he was a deacon at the second baptist
church he also
uh sang in the choir
and was in charge of the local bus
program
so like i said
so halloween comes 1974.
mr o'brien takes his two children
trick-or-treating
in pasadena texas the neighborhood
where they lived now
mr o'brien and his uh neighbor also had
two children
they also they all go out together oh my
god did you find a pookie yeah she's up
in the top apartment she's still
sleeping up in there
why is she sleeping at this time of day
i don't know that seems very odd
yeah i hope she's okay she's fine
well it seems weird for her to be
sleeping at this time
we don't know that kitty's sleeping
patterns yeah i do
actually she must have stayed awake
she's up in there looking at me going
get out of here
i was like all right although i have to
say she was like
making bread on my head at like [ __ ]
6am making biscuits
yeah okay she just like comes up and
she's like hey
i'm gonna get all about that
so okay so mr o'brien takes his children
trick-or-treating
with a neighbor who also has some
children now
they go around the neighborhood not to a
huge amount of houses
but they go to this one house and
whoever
is in the house doesn't answer the door
so at this point like the two kids are
like [ __ ] this man and they go
to the next house but ronald
stays at this house
now he catches up with the group
of his kids and his neighbors and he's
like hey that dude actually
did eventually answer the door and here
he gave you guys some pixie stix
five of them so he pulls him out and he
puts him in all the kids bags
so like i said he gives one to his
son one to his daughter one to his um
one hd each of his two children's uh
neighbor's children
and one to this other like 10 year old
kid that like [ __ ] wander by
now so they go back home
now timothy mr o'brien's son
um says that he's like man can i have
some candy before i go to bed so his
parents say of course you can it's
halloween
so he decides that he's going to have
the pixie stick
and he's like oh i have a hard time like
getting it open
because it was like stapled shut so
uh his dad like helps him open it
and like get the powder all loose and
stuff yeah you know
have that pixie stick this is gonna be
like [ __ ] up later on
so the kid eats the pixie stick which
like i said if you're not in the u.s i
don't know if you know what a pixie
stick is
they have well they have like little
bitty ones that are like like a regular
straw size and then they have like
big these were 21 inch ones so these are
kind of like the big ones yeah it's a
big 21 inch [ __ ] plastic
it's a straw and it's basically full of
like flavored sugar
yeah and you basically like cut it open
and you like you like
what it really is is pretty sweet and
kool-aid mix
yeah it's kind of like that you can drop
that into water and it makes kool-aid
i've tried it if you put enough in there
it's just
yeah kool-aid mix but if you have it in
a tube for some reason when you were a
kid
pouring it into your mouth there was
something about it it was just like
it was like there's a [ __ ] you
remember those like lickham kind of
things they came with like that [ __ ]
it was like a vanilla flavored like
candy stick and you kind of licked it
and then you like
dipped it in the powder and then you
like licked it again yeah
it's [ __ ] pre-sweetened kool-aid
which is a drink essentially yeah that's
what it is that's what it didn't come in
any flavor
yeah but these ones mostly like fruit
and grape and
that was it yeah it was like well it was
like red flavored
which was like kind of like strawberry
and cherry-ish flavored
and then you had like a [ __ ] blue
which is blue flavored which was usually
kind of raspberry-ish or grapeish
there's a red and then there was a green
and then green was usually
appley yeah flaming lime
which yeah okay that was a lemon lime i
don't even i had them all i loved them
things
a lot of people did yeah but these were
apparently i mean 21 inches that's
pretty big so these were like the bigger
like plastic ones
it was [ __ ] almost as tall as you so
it was like you hit the jackpot
right you were only score you were only
a half inch in diameter little bitty
[ __ ] plastic tube
sealed at either end yeah they were like
about that big around
yeah with a label on the top of it and
it was just like
it was drink mix it's what it was
probably [ __ ] kool-aid drink mix it's
just repackaged
and uh we loved it well the same way
little kids [ __ ] drink the kool-aid
out of the [ __ ] little jar you know
[ __ ] plastic yeah put
you know put a spoon in it here take
that
yeah i liked all that sweet [ __ ] sweet
sour stuff
i did too powdery stuff i liked powder i
liked pixie six too which
like i said probably would have killed
me a normal pixie stick though was the
size of a drinking straw it was [ __ ]
yeah they were usually like drinking
straws yeah they were like kind of like
not like plastic drawers but they were
kind of like paper straws wax paper and
they were folded down on each end
yeah with a spiral color spiral shirt
white with a spiral color going on there
like purple or green or whatever and you
bit the top of it off and you poured it
into your mouth
oh yeah like you did something and it
was just [ __ ]
cool it was like snorting coke yeah when
you were a kid 70 [ __ ]
it was yeah well i kind of feel like
that's
sadly what happened in this situation
was that
so the kid is like given the choice of
like yeah you can have some candy
from your bag and the one thing he
picked unfortunately
was the pixie stick which like i said
was apparently a big one
so he took it and then
like his dad he couldn't get it open
because it had been like stapled shut
so his dad comes in and somebody like
yeah let me help you with that
and he helped him open it and like
loosen the powder and stuff
and then timothy like eats the powder
and he's like wow man that tastes really
funny it's like really bitter it doesn't
taste really good
and then like a minute or two later
he said that his stomach was hurting and
then he runs to the bathroom
and starts throwing up and convulsing
yeah
poison yeah yeah obviously
and so the dad mr o'brien
um he later claimed he's like oh i was
holding timothy his ten-year-old son in
his arms he was throwing up
and then the kid went limp in his arms
they called the hospital
or they called the ambulance they put
timothy in the ambulance and he died
on the way to the hospital less than an
hour after he had consumed the candy
now because he had died from purportedly
poisoned halloween candy like i said i
think urban legends about that [ __ ] had
already been circulating at this point
but this was the thing that really like
codified it into the american
consciousness as a thing you know what
i'm saying
because this happened like back in the
70s
and so this was something that's like
there's psychos out there that are like
poisoning halloween candy and i feel
like that was like kind of
in the gestalt of the time
so apparently um the dad
used this to his advantage because
he was like well some psycho
must have put some poison into this
kid's
like candy and i'm not responsible like
i don't know anything about it
so they didn't really like the cops
didn't really suspect the dad
until later like they do the autopsy on
the kid
and they find that he had been killed
with
uh you know potassium cyanide which
if you watched last week's show that was
the same [ __ ] they used to that
that psycho put in the time and the
tylenol bottles
and it kills very you don't need a lot
and it kills
very quickly sophie jumped in how you
doing sophie
you gotta go back to go party with her
family oh thank you very much for the
cupcakes
yeah if i remember wasn't this a black
family
no it wasn't okay i thought it was a
black guy that [ __ ] did this
nope okay nope white dude all right it's
a white dude it's a white dude thing yes
it was
now um so like i said this dude
once they kind of like figured out what
had killed the guy
or killed the kid they're like okay we
need to look back at this and then they
started like suspecting his dad
because like i said the dad they
questioned him
but they're like okay well where was the
house that you got these pixie sticks
from and he said he
couldn't remember yeah
even though they'd only been to like two
blocks worth of houses
so yeah you would remember where you got
the [ __ ] pixie stix from
so the fact that he didn't remember the
like made them very suspicious
now luckily he had given poisoned
pixie sticks to his daughter
two of his neighbor kids and also a
ten-year-old like stranger kid that just
like happened to be
there because he was trying to
cover his tracks yeah he's trying to
make it look like
some random halloween psycho that was
like poisoning
i know where i got the idea that it was
might have been a black guy
it was a black guy that [ __ ] did
those random shootings to try to [ __ ]
um
remember that from the trunk there's a
black guy in the blood in the trunk
yeah he had the black kid in the trunk
and they were using an ar-15 to shoot
random people
but one of the one of the random people
they were going to shoot was his ex-wife
that way he could get custody of his
kids
remember when that happened i think i
know what case your doctor that's what
it was the same
idea as that guy okay that's why that's
why
i are you like ready to talk because i
gotta pee
i'll go ahead okay well you wanna run
the commercials well
i don't have any commercials you have
any commercials so just talk okay i'll
talk to them just talk
let's see how everybody's doing go ahead
go ahead and
um see what you guys are up to
sophie's up in michigan how cold is it
in michigan
so i used to live in michigan [ __ ] i
just like it up there during the winter
time manage it was [ __ ] cold
sometimes it was snow it would get like
[ __ ] five feet of [ __ ] snow
in the suburbs
michigan was like michigan is like the
american version of
siberia that's the american siberia
detroit and [ __ ]
it's like a land of robocop and [ __ ]
axophobia and [ __ ] for [ __ ] way
sophie had never seen axel foley from
beverly hills cop
i showed her that movie she's like oh
yeah this movie is detroit as [ __ ]
she liked it she liked it showing her
some of her history
everybody want to start talking to
sophie now
i can't believe jenny didn't have any
damn kitty videos set up
this [ __ ] show is awesome because we
have we can we can [ __ ] talk
about crime we can
do all this [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
live [ __ ] and then show
kitty videos as a commercial it's
unbelievable
[Music]
ah
yeah michigan has robocop mission's got
robocop and got [ __ ] axo foley
here she come off yeah
all right she's dead i don't even like
gone through my candy what'd you talk
about while it's gone
nothing nothing yeah
you guys should do a show about the dc
sniper i've thought about that actually
i think it's on the topic list
aren't y'all glad you started doing live
shows
oh yeah we are actually i didn't think i
would like it
because i thought because you know how i
am i'm like really like
control oh my god i'm like mess up and
i'm like i like being able to like edit
out all the times that i say um
i always my place and stuff i always
like live
you know more than anything else it's
kind of better well i like the way
i like that we can like interact with
people it's like if we don't have
anything to talk about like you guys can
like ask us questions and i was like
yeah we like you know are we still doing
this are we
still on this third one about the pixie
stick murders yeah yeah we didn't finish
it okay
i haven't finished it yeah i'm trying to
eat candy i can't eat candy because i'm
trying to like
what i can't what yeah okay so
like i said so not only did this [ __ ]
give poison to his own son
and his own daughter but he also gave it
to three like [ __ ] random kids
because he thought well that'll cover
the [ __ ] crime up
and make it look like i didn't straight
up murder my children
because apparently the plan was
to murder his two kids because
insurance money yeah because he was like
apparently i'll like a hundred thousand
dollars in debt
like you do yeah like you do you have to
[ __ ] cover your debt by killing and
yeah sure that's like the first thing a
normal person would think of it's like
dude i'm a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
i'm gonna take out some insurance
policies on my children
and then poison them on halloween so it
looks like some random
person did it and i'm going to collect
all this money
dude profit
what about the wife
i don't think she knew anything about
this [ __ ] what was the plan
him and the wife would go [ __ ] move
off to [ __ ] tahiti or something or
what
i mean did he really think that like the
wife was gonna be like oh yeah
okay my kids are dead so yeah that's the
answer so yeah that's the end of the
chapter let's like go and like [ __ ] it
yeah yeah i think that's maybe what you
thought
are you are these dudes really that dumb
i thought that that one was i thought
that hurts
that one was yeah i mean fine with it
she'll shake it off and we'll get out of
here
we'll go to tahiti i mean do you really
think because like i said i think that
he was
initially planning to kill both the
children because he did like
give them both the poison pixie stix it
just happened
that timothy was the only one that
actually ate the pixie sticks
the other kids had them they just hadn't
eaten them yet he's probably gonna kill
the wife too
if he got away with that one how much
somebody's gonna kill a wife too
yeah seriously i don't understand this
like compounding your error kind of [ __ ]
he was gonna use the wife to he's gonna
use the kids to pay off the debt
and then once that [ __ ] [ __ ] flew
then he was gonna kill the wife
to make profit then he'd move on and get
a [ __ ] younger
younger girlfriend i mean did anybody
think that like because
as i told you i researched true crime
cases
90 95 of the time
a woman dies a child dies yeah it is
it's the dude their dad yeah it's just
or their stepdad it's statistics i mean
statistically
not always like sometimes it's just a
random stranger
but most of the time that is why
police will bring in the husband the
ex-boyfriend that somebody
that because that is overwhelmingly the
person that has done it overwhelmingly
is statistics i mean yeah if the wife
dies in a plane crash the husband didn't
do it
if the wife dies of [ __ ] cancer the
husband didn't do it
it's if that wife dies in unexplained
ways
statistically you might want to probably
probably yeah right i mean 95
of the time yeah right like i said i've
written about this
time um or is it or is it just
damn near yeah damn here well that's why
people don't die for no reason that's
that's really what it is
yeah and if you don't know the reason
chances are and you can't [ __ ] find a
medical reason it's probably murder
it's usually somebody that knows them
and a lot of times it's the person
that's married to them sad to say
i mean like i said statistics well
statistically
when women die when children die it is
usually either the man that is involved
in their life right now
or the man that was involved in their
life it's usually like the ex-husband
the ex-boyfriend or the current
yeah like i said boyfriend it's not all
deaths
it's not all deaths though it's just
like friends
if a child dies a [ __ ] leukemia
it's not the [ __ ] no i'm talking
about murders you're right if
it's mysterious death so we're talking
about a lot of times this
and that's what i'm saying about this
and this is that's what's shitty about
this case that's what pisses me off
about this case and like why the fact
that they called it the men who killed
halloween
because this dude is
almost single-handedly responsible
for the whole [ __ ] urban legend about
oh some psycho is gonna put razor blades
in the apples or is going to put like
[ __ ] poison in your candy
it was this dude and he was trying to
kill
his own children and making it
look like a psycho stranger did it
that's kind of like and him doing that
made everybody flip their [ __ ]
and that like it just goes to show like
one [ __ ] [ __ ]
ruins it for everybody because that's
what this
that's what this dude did and he
succeeded in killing his
own child and he probably wanted to kill
his daughter too
to be fair but she didn't eat the pixie
stick and
thankfully none of the other children
that he gave the pixie
pixie stix too like ate them because
they were kind of like uh whatever and
they like
but the shitty thing about it is that
one of the kids he gave the pixie stick
to like there's just this random kid
um he was actually gonna eat it but
his parents were like they found out
about like the poison pixie stick and
they were like flipping out yeah
well no and they were like flipping out
and they're like holy [ __ ] like we can't
find it
yeah and so they ran up to the kids room
and they
found the kid he had the pixie stick in
his hands but like it was in bed with
him
but he hadn't eaten it because he
couldn't get the staple open
because that's what the dude did he put
the poison in like the first like
like third of the pixie stick and then
like he because he opened it and then
like he stapled it back shut
and i guess the kid couldn't get the
staple open so he was like [ __ ] it and
he just fell asleep
and he didn't eat it yeah got lucky so
that kid almost could have died
like this just a random kid yeah that
was just like kind of like hey what
what you got there mister you got some
candy holy crap
yeah so honestly well the good thing
about this
is statistically this is not [ __ ]
normal [ __ ] that happens that's what i'm
saying
happens it's just it was a ra it was a
one-off
i mean it's good probably to like check
your kids candy
fine it's like just make sure another
shit's open like nobody gives you like
any [ __ ] homemade [ __ ] don't eat that
but it's like i feel like if [ __ ] is
just like pre-packaged
aside from like what people what most
people like believe most people
are okay most people will not do
anything to hurt anybody i saw a program
on this random [ __ ] do not
poison candy
it does it doesn't happen well why would
there's been no there's been no incident
of that
no because the kind of dude that would
randomly poison candy and hand it out at
the [ __ ]
at the doorstep during halloween would
know that they could easily catch him
well yeah everyone will remember that
[ __ ] dude's house
yeah it was just this one one-off case
and that was his own kid yeah people
people don't hand out poison to candy
if you want to kill somebody there's a
lot more efficient ways of doing it
and you'll never get away with it this
way no so
it was just a hoax the dude was playing
i mean
dude was poison his own kid trying to
blame it on somebody else
that's all it was i feel like between
this and between the timeline all
murders which we talked about last week
i can see why people would be alarmed
because the tylenol murders that was
indeed some weird psycho that was just
like hey i'm gonna put cyanide in
[ __ ] towel them i'll just put them
back on the [ __ ] drugstore shelves
where everyone where anyone could buy
them like i get that that would be
alarming
that's very different from handing it
out to your front door right
that yeah that is kind of alarming but
it's so i
understand why people would freak out
but
i feel like it's a miss you know it's
it's just not a fear that you should be
like [ __ ] consumed with
no i just feel like it doesn't it
doesn't happen
no yeah and anything that has to do with
like poison halloween candy it's like
everything like that all of the urban
legends about that
come back to this dude yeah and this
dude
was just trying to kill his own children
for insurance money right and trying to
make it look like it was [ __ ] random
yeah
and it's impossible you can't do it
i mean he ended up poisoning if you
handed out poison candy out of your own
front door
you have a zero percent chance of
getting away with it
and this dude did not it took him a
while it took the police a while because
at first they did like buy that whole
like it was just some random weirdo
but they traced the candy finally back
back to
the house where he said that he got the
[ __ ] from
and that dude was not even home he was
like at work and he could prove it
right so finally they're like oh well
maybe the dad did it
so then they look into the dead and it
turns out that the dad
had had like a hundred thousand dollars
which today is more than half a million
dollars
in life insurance on his children yeah
which is an anomaly
and he was in like a whole bunch of debt
yeah people don't do that
and finally like when they questioned
him and [ __ ] he was like
yeah i did that [ __ ] the average
[ __ ] doesn't take out big life
insurance policies on his kids and his
wife when everybody's young it just
doesn't happen
i think even the insurance company was
just kind of like dude
yeah they don't do it i think even they
thought it was weird
but yeah yeah like his car was about to
be
repo'ed he was going to get fired from
his job
what kind of [ __ ] was going on so it's
like the more they like
in investigated that [ __ ] they're like
yeah he [ __ ] did yeah the whole life
insurance scam we can
if you go back into our shows we'll see
life insurance murderers goes back to
the 1800s
it's an old scam and they didn't really
get away with it back then too much
maybe you could kill one or two of your
[ __ ] wallets that way
they would eventually they eventually
got onto your ass
even with that primitive technology they
had back then well cops would
slowly track you down the thing that
kills me is just that
one it seems like even one time it seems
very suspicious
yeah but if you did it two three two
take out a life insurance policy
on a wife a young wife right when when
they were very are your children or
whatever that seems very suspicious
okay but okay but if you do it
again right and again and again and it
just didn't make any [ __ ] sense
these dudes were [ __ ] taking life and
service assurance policies out on 20
year old wives
and then they were dead a few months
later that's a huge [ __ ] red flag
that's what i mean 20 year olds
don't they don't generally they just
don't die right
and they don't die in bathtubs they
usually kill killed in bathtubs
grabbing by the [ __ ] ankles like that
drowning in a damn bathtub yeah this
didn't happen
yeah that's like um you do you can only
do that so many times before people
start to get suspicious
well i think even doing it the first
time they were suspicious but they
couldn't prove anything
well that's what i mean by the time you
did again and they were like ah
if you're gonna do that [ __ ] you can
only do it once yeah
and because after after a second time
people are gonna start being like come
on now
yeah and the payouts from what i
remember what weren't much
no remember that that dude that was
doing that was
drowning yeah [ __ ] wives and [ __ ]
that was a british guy i think
there's a british he was in america okay
well maybe there was more than one
yeah eight late 1800s early 1900s and he
wasn't getting but what five
five thousand dollars well wait five
thousand dollars in
those days money or five thousand
dollars in today in those days money
well that's a lot of money that's not
enough to risk your [ __ ] life because
they hung that dude
well no they hung that dude eventually
when they got him you got like two or
three of them
well that's what i mean like well for a
normal person like me
yeah you're like that amount right that
amount of money is like not worth it
not worth dying for no
but for some people i guess it is
because they don't like yeah and then
and it was like pretty wives it was just
[ __ ] crazy and he wasn't like
he wasn't a catch to begin with but he
was nowadays he would have been a serial
killer i don't remember that dude's name
well there were a lot of ones like that
yeah i don't know weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] weird [ __ ] yes
the shitty thing about this dude too was
that
not only did they be like okay well he
took out all these life insurance
policies
on his children which weird
that's a red flag like i said but also
like a lot of his like work colleagues
were like yeah man
last couple months he's been super
interested in
cyanide as a general principle and how
much it would take like to kill a person
and where you could get it and also
there was like a chemical supply
warehouse
that said that he had called there and
was like trying to buy some
but then he got bummed out because
apparently from this chemical supply
warehouse you could only buy
five pounds at a time because they
weren't like just gonna sell like
hey i'm just gonna sell you this little
vial that you could poison somebody with
you had to like buy a whole [ __ ] ton
and he was evidently not prepared to do
that so
all the uh employees of this chemical
warehouse also came forward later and
was like yeah he was trying to like buy
cyanide but would not buy five pounds at
a time
because he didn't need it because he was
only just trying to like poison a few
people
so yeah special but yes they're saying
stick a fork and tommy's done
yeah i'm kind of loaded well a little
bit we'll get done in a minute but
one more case i think we got one more
case yeah but
yeah like i said so this dude finally he
finally got arrested
in uh actually it was team finally it
was just like a few days later
it was early november 1974 um because
they didn't buy his [ __ ]
um you know so he eventually
got sentenced to death and was executed
like his execution was like um
postponed for a very long time because
they were like oh we still got an appeal
blah blah blah but he eventually did get
uh
executed so i'm sure all of you will
happy
be happy to know that and um also
there were a bunch of people that came
to his execution
and when he got executed all of them
were outside going
trick-or-treat [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what as he got electrocuted so you know
i'm not a big
death penalty advocate but oh i am
okay i say kill the [ __ ] i'm not
i'm not upset about it in this case
because that's your own [ __ ] kids man
yeah and like i said he killed the one
kid only because the kid ate the [ __ ]
[ __ ] if his daughter had eaten it she'd
be dead too
and so would two of the neighbor kids
and a third random kid
only the fact that they didn't eat it
that was the only
like reason why they didn't die
so now let's talk about a whole family
getting murdered now this was like um
actually fairly recent this only
happened in 2010.
so this happened in ohio
so there's this dude named devin griffin
he's
uh coming home he was in his church
choir
it was a sunday morning and he comes
home after being like he was singing in
the church choir
and he comes home and uh
he was 16 years old at this time
he goes up to his bedroom he's gonna
like hang out play video games or
whatever
and he starts to like notice something's
kind of weird like in the house it's
very like
quiet it's only 1 30 in the afternoon
um but he's like you know i don't really
know
like where any of my family members are
it's very unusual for them like not to
be
around or like making noise at this time
so we had a mom susan lisk she actually
works
uh night shifts so he said it wasn't
strange for her to like sleep late
because she was like up all night oh
there's somebody at the front door
what oh is that her trick or treaters oh
my goodness we didn't think we would get
any
i didn't think we would get any he soup
did he eat all my candy okay this is
candy
all right so he's like all right so she
works night shift but she's never slept
till like 1 30 in the afternoon that's
like
that's not something that usually
happens so
he decides he's like okay i'm gonna go
downstairs
uh because he had a room up in the attic
and he's like i'm gonna go
like knock on the door of the master
bedroom and see what the [ __ ] is going
on
were there it was like a big old 15 year
old wonder woman
a big old 15 year old wonder woman yeah
i was like you're a grown woman
she looked like she was [ __ ] hey she
almost looked like she was [ __ ] six
feet tall
right here here you go she looking
around and she's looking at me like
what's this old man dressed up last
night
it's like it's a long story yeah is that
what you're doing you don't understand
the show you don't understand you don't
understand
that's the only trick-or-treater we've
had yeah all night right
yeah yeah well i figured not a lot of
people would be trick-or-treating no
and she was like almost old enough to be
at the club okay
look like her yeah like i said i'm i'm
not gonna like [ __ ] on anybody for
getting like
candy this time of year she might have
been older than that she looked like she
was about like
some of our friends from the club you
know what i mean
elsa says maybe she couldn't tell it was
a costume yeah i don't know yeah that's
right what it was maybe she
thought that's what you look like yeah
really
exactly it's just like it's funny
because your costume is like funny to me
but it's like
other people probably wouldn't even know
i feel like it only a tiny percentage of
people have seen that movie so it's like
they don't really know
and they're just like and then you have
to explain it and then it's not fun
anymore
but yeah so yeah so devin is like okay
well
mom works late shift but she's never
she's never asleep at like 1 30 in the
afternoon what the [ __ ] is going on
so he knocks on the door of the master
bedroom there's no answer
so he opens the door which is not locked
he finds his mom
laying in bed next to his stepfather his
name was william lisk
senior um and the comforter had been
like pulled over their
heads so devin's like okay um are you
guys like getting up today or what it's
like 1
30 and nobody answers so he's like he
walks around
and then he sees his mom's foot like
coming out from front of the
comforter so he's like poking at the
foot
nothing happens so he's like she doesn't
wake up so he thinks that's really weird
so he pulls down the covers a little bit
and he sees that the covers um and the
pillow
are like covered with blood
so at that point he's just like
i think he kind of like freaked out at
this point because it's like it's
halloween and he feels like maybe
my family are like pulling this weird
like sick
prank on me like they're all pretending
to be like corpses
i kind of feel like that's what you
thought well that's what you would think
i suppose
you wouldn't like think that your whole
[ __ ] family was murdered even though
that's what happened in this situation
everybody's talking about i hate it when
these
older kids are out there [ __ ] trick
or treating so yeah i don't mind it like
she's like laura you know our friend
laura yeah ross she looked like that
dressed in a [ __ ] wonder woman
costume she's probably
16 17 actually like i said
verging on the age of being on a damn
[ __ ] stripper pole
oh my goodness yeah yeah that's what it
looked like like a couple years away
from that
we're the worst you should have been up
there with me handing out candy
do you want me to go now i'm just wait
what time is it okay
you look like laura
she had a big [ __ ] silver big old
[ __ ] red and gold [ __ ] sparkly
cape and [ __ ]
dude alicia in a costume yeah she had
the costume the only time i get
look the only time i get upset is when
these 15 16 17 year olds come to the
door with just [ __ ] hoodies on
yeah just a hoodie yeah give me some
candy like if you have a costume on
no fine i don't care how old you are you
could be like an old [ __ ] man
if you have a costume on and you like
went to the effort i'll give you candy
yeah no she had a
full [ __ ] water world cup bustier
like i said age is not a is not a factor
effort
is a factor she had a bustier and cape
and the [ __ ] big old tall knee-high
boots
all right that's what i mean yeah legit
yeah legit yeah tiara
yeah look up the song look you you guys
look up the song my sister sent me this
song many years ago
it's by the swinging neckbreakers and
it's called no costume no candy
yeah and that is my
mantra at halloween you can be as old
as you want to be as long as you made
the effort
to have a costume and it's like a
recognizable costume
um like i said don't just come to my
door in a [ __ ] hoodie and jeans and
[ __ ] like that and what's a free candy
[ __ ] off but if you have a costume on
all right yeah tila's laughing tom
yeah i'd give the milf milf can't was it
was this a milf [ __ ]
yeah i'd give candy to a milf in class
but she wasn't a milf
she was she was a teenager but
i'm a girl oh an older teenager
yeah she's a middle well not exactly
yeah not really but cougar she's a
cougar
yeah that's a more accurate description
[Laughter]
but yeah yeah so where was i
i don't know okay so this poor kid
who like i said is 16 he thinks that his
whole family has decided to play a
halloween prank on him by
all pretending to be dead bodies which
like
that i don't know that breaks my heart
but so
he's like looking at it being like what
the [ __ ] and he's like
so he looks at his mom and then finally
he sees like this big
like her [ __ ] neck is like all
it's like this big wound and there's all
like [ __ ] blood and it's like
how's that drinking gabs and [ __ ] um i
saw that like a third left
okay i'm gonna get some more all right
so at this stage devon figures out
[ __ ] man this is not um
this is not a prank and this is [ __ ]
up so he runs out of the house
he goes to the neighbor's house and he
tells them to call
uh 911. so they do now
this dude okay so
the authorities get there now they find
53 year old
william liske who i guess was uh devin's
stepdad
and uh susan liske was the mom she was
46
and they also found another person 23
year old
derek griffin who was the son they were
all in this house
and they had all been murdered now
all of their murders according to
preliminary
coroner's exams had been caused by
gunshot or blunt object they were all
[ __ ] up so they couldn't really tell
now at this stage they had someone
who identified a suspect
this was 24 year old william lisk
jr now he was the son of the murdered
father now this was the previous
marriage of the father so this was like
a son from her previous marriage
now so as soon as he was identified as a
suspect
they eventually tracked him down and
they arrested him
like 200 miles away now he gets
charged initially with one count of
first-degree murder and
um so then they're like
where did he go sorry i lost my place
cook is still in the [ __ ] bowl
is she really yeah still on the bone
she's sleeping like that i'm looking she
taught him talking to her and she's like
yeah yeah
that's very well that's very strange
because yeah this hour
she doesn't usually um sleep at this
time of day usually at this time of day
she's like it's dark out i want to go
out well she's not sleeping she's just
relaxing
relaxing listening to us talk that's
what she's doing
i hope she's okay yeah looks happy
okay well i hope so
so evidently this william liske jr
person
who they suspect of killing his entire
former family
um the fact that he had killed his
entire family was not like a big shock
to anyone
because apparently as far back as 2002
and keep in mind that these murders
happen in 2010
um his real dad bill had actually called
the cops um several times
because uh william who was then 16 years
old
had uh threatened to kill himself and
threaten to like hurt other people
etc now at the time back in 2002
he was under house arrest for uh other
things
like he had a bunch of other things
going on
so um apparently like cops came to like
arrest him for various things and he
would like attack the cops
um he also later faced charges in
juvenile court for assaulting a
a peace officer and in 2004
he actually got into a fight with his
stepmother
and struck her in the chest
he also got um a couple months after
that also in 2004
he got assault charges and robbery for
hitting his stepmother
susan with a coffee cup and then
stealing her
car keys so at this stage
in 2004 he had been put on trial
but he was found like incompetent
to stand trial because he had like
mental problems apparently
so they moved him to a mental home like
a group home for people with
mental health problems and also
um around this time he also got into
trouble for
his uh getting into a fight with his dad
and um various other things
so apparently like this kid
had decided that he was
thank you mary happy halloween guys love
the costumes thank you thank you very
much man
thank you seriously we've only had one
trick-or-treater all night there was
like a
yeah 16 year old girl yeah she did you
did you seriously eat all that candy and
i didn't get it no you ate so many times
i used to say that
we ate about half of it each that one
you want more
that looks like more than half of you
want more i feel like i only got like
three pieces
that's all it is it's all in your
imagination
it's all in your magic are you trying to
gaslight me i'm guessing no
i'm talking about it how much candy i
eat i'll bring you some more
just like well hey man if the if the
trick-or-treaters aren't coming i'm
gonna eat that [ __ ]
i don't care i'm gonna get fat so
so the thing about it though is that so
this kid
has apparently been troubled for a long
time
now the thing about it though is that
his dad
seems to have like so his stepmom
also like alleged that he sexually
assaulted her
which given everything we know about
this dude i'm not like super
surprised um by that but
the dad seemed to have like been like
it's my son and i'm just gonna like
stand up for him whatever
so he oh thanks got twix in it and
everything
okay well damn that's a lot so he kind
of like stuck up for the kid
and he tried to like get him out of
trouble even though
probably he could have benefited from it
so i do feel like maybe the dad had a
little bit of
culpability in this as well
so they finally bring in this kid
william listen lisk jr and uh
he when they bring him into trial
he actually uh admitted guilt three
counts of murder for
murdering his whole entire family um
and he said that
he didn't really um he didn't have an
excuse
as to like why you done it or he didn't
have any reason to why he'd done it
he was just kind of like i don't really
have any reason or
any excuses to like why i decided to
kill my whole entire family
on halloween um i really loved my dad
so i don't really know why
and it's like when i think about it i
just feel really
sick that i think about that i killed my
whole family
he killed his whole [ __ ] family damn
on halloween
16 years old or however it was i missed
it how do you do it
um he either shot them or bludgeoned
them damn
so it was like some [ __ ] ronnie defeo
[ __ ] yeah like going around the [ __ ]
ammunition
that's the [ __ ] thing that i thought
of yeah it's funny because we were just
like
when we were just watching something
about the amityville horror last night
what was that yeah it was it was um oh
we're like welcome to the basement
welcome to the basement that's right
they did a show about am the andy
belcher the movie
and the thing about the movie like we
did a show about the amityville horror
but it was a long time ago
i don't believe any of the haunting [ __ ]
was real because like i said
[ __ ] and lorraine were involved in
that and
it was more than that but like the [ __ ]
that happened
well yeah there was that whole thing
right but before the like all the
haunting [ __ ] happened
like a dude did kill his entire family
in that house and that is that is not
disputed
now one thing that always bothered me
about that case and they brought it up
on welcome to the basement
and it's in the movie as well and this
was something that bothered me about the
movie even was a kid
was that ronnie defeo allegedly
went around the house and shot his whole
entire family
one by one and you would think that
somebody shooting somebody you'd think
that the other family members would wake
up
but we were talking about that yeah the
thing is though is look
you want me to chime in and give you my
i do that's why i'm asking because we
were talking about this last night we
were talking about the ambivale horror
it was a
it was a 444 marlin lever action it was
they're very [ __ ] loud all right it's
like uh
much bigger than 44 magnum it's like a
very large straight walled pistol case
was like it's [ __ ] pretty loud
but it's not really a high compression
like say like
high-powered rifle cartridge which means
that the pitch is not
real intense it's kind of like boom
instead of crack
you know i think what he did was he
[ __ ]
opened up the door of his dad and mom's
room he shot the dad in the back web
just asleep
boom that woke up the mother he jacked
them around in the [ __ ] chamber and
nailed her boom
as she was getting that well before she
even like had a chance
i get that right and he went back out in
the hallway
and the kids were just waking up at that
time and he must have said something
to them all that caused them to cower in
their beds
he went down to the [ __ ] his his
sister's room
who was next in line in terms of age she
was a little bit
she was older than the than the children
she was a couple years younger than him
that he was 17 18.
yeah and he walked in and she was in bed
and [ __ ] he said something to her and
blasted her boom
the little kids were [ __ ] cowering in
there thank you michael
thank you very much the little kids are
cowering in their beds
i know what it's like to be really
scared while you're in bed sure
there's poultry guys [ __ ] going on you
know they were like rabbits they just
froze and he shot him in the back while
they were in bed the two little boys
so if you're moving fast enough and it's
just overwhelming force and horror
and you have the target priorities right
the dad the mom the older sister
after that you got the little boys you'd
kill them while they were all in bed
paralyzed with fear
later on the way the damn crime scene
would look it would look very mysterious
why are they all still in bed
you know that oh that scared the [ __ ]
right why are they still in bed what
couldn't they hear what was going on
well
yeah they could hear what's going on but
by the time they fully knew what was
going on the only ones that were
surviving were the boys
they were terrified they were [ __ ]
trying when you're a little kid they're
hiding underneath the covers from the
bullets imagine being a little kid
yeah and you hear yeah gunshots
like you don't necessarily hear screams
you don't necessarily hear any of that
it's like would you necessarily believe
that somebody particularly your brother
was going around like shooting your
whole entire family
yeah you wouldn't believe that i
wouldn't have believed that when i was
little
well i think they knew but i think the
little boys knew but they only had a few
seconds to process it
and by the time the older sister was
dead
they were just like rabbits frozen in
fear that's what i'm trying to hide
underneath the damn covers
that's kind of the covers don't stop
bullets well no
but when you're a little when you're
only monsters yeah but when you're a
little boy you don't
realize that yeah i mean the covers
don't stop bullets that's true
somebody said earlier that um they'd
heard um
the rumor that one of the sisters that
helped him which i had heard that also
well there was only one sister the older
one yeah
i don't think i don't know if that's
true or not it could be but
i don't know it's when you see
surveillance photos of real
shootings or if you see them in person
which i have
i've seen deadly shooties in person i've
seen a lot of dead bodies
in person from accidents and [ __ ]
jenny knows the whole [ __ ] story but
go look at video surveillance of a
[ __ ] mass shooting
four or five people you would be
astounded at how
fast it happens well it's very quick and
like i said by the time
like it's something that a normal person
is not they can't process it
they focus yeah yeah because most people
would because it's like it's not
something you deal with in your everyday
life you're just like what the [ __ ] is
going on you wouldn't know what was
going on
the shooter knows exactly what's going
on and he's amped up and he's going boom
boom
and then he's running to somebody's boom
boom
boom and it's just that fast
just that fast yeah not even a minute
they can't react to it i was listening
to something the other day about
somebody that had been
in the parkland shooting and they were
just kind of like
nobody knew what was going on for a long
time
it's like we were at the other we were
in another part of the school it's like
we just heard noises but we just thought
it was fireworks and it's like there was
a fire drill it's like we'd had a fire
drill earlier it's like no one really
thought anything about it
so it was like if you don't see the [ __ ]
happening in front of you
you don't necessarily think that this
horrible like
[ __ ] [ __ ] is happening yeah i mean
like i said your whole entire family
getting massacred
by your brother michael schaefer says
you guys are the greatest
even you tom you're magnificent
and no i'm not gay well let me tell you
something michael
you'd be gay when i was done with you
you'd be
gay as [ __ ] when i was done with you
mike my goodness ain't that something
okay notice it was sanders i'm just
gonna walk away from it
like it didn't happen it was recorded
though you know that right what's that
it was recorded though you know that
right what was recorded what you just
said
of course it recorded i don't care if it
was recorded i'm gonna pretend like
it'll be online forever
oh yeah put a [ __ ] underline
underneath it
[ __ ] flipping [ __ ] since 1969.
hold on since you were an infant
since i was an infant i was [ __ ]
flipping [ __ ]
my dad never saw their father kill their
grandmother with a shotgun
blast to the chest when they're five and
seven didn't come out of the whisper in
three days
this is back in the 30s so michael said
see i get that yeah because like i said
it's not i mean thankfully
it's not something that exit only buddy
no it's okay
okay exit the gate doesn't have to be a
physical gate it could be a spiritual
game
it's where a [ __ ] soul can
you're a spiritual guy yes soul coming
out
soul rape you and then come back in you
wouldn't you couldn't even stop it
and he wouldn't be gay because how could
a [ __ ] like you ever be a man
next to me
it would still be a woman that compared
to me we're talking about it's not gay
straight
tell them jenny
okay that's it jenny doesn't want to
play those games
michael it's all fun and games bro well
like i said i
i get annoyed because i do kind of feel
like yeah being womanly is always kind
of
joy joy is good spiritual gay yeah it's
spiritual gay
it's always considered like it's just
not as good
not as good it's not an actual gay or a
physical gay it's a spiritual gay
like crustal that's a spiritual is he
spiritually gay
spiritually yeah spiritually he's gay
yeah i guess
you were gay with crusoe that that might
happen we don't know
the [ __ ] the shit's happening in another
dimension i'm already picturing this
it's happening in another dimension i'm
picturing the family kurt russell
and david bowie and you watch it
and you just you watch there it is
and it's not not only watching i'm
filming because
i'm not a prophet but it's not actual
it's not
actual it's spiritual and it's just it's
just
uh it's it's an entertainment based
sexuality
not an identity-based sexuality an
entertainment entertainment basically
that's an intriguing concept isn't it
[ __ ] man get back to the show again ken
says
i must have conf i must confess there's
a lesbian in me dying to get out
yes yeah yeah exactly
same here well i have a lesbian and a
gay man inside me dying to get out
that's [ __ ] funny i don't have any
straight people in here but it's like
it's all part of the uh it's all part of
the entertainment
people takes you too seriously well you
know
we we try to be what i'm trying to like
look i'm trying to eat all the
it's like kanye a lot of people don't
understand you know the first time i
heard kanye's song gay fish that's when
i
that's when i really clicked that he
could write
even though he didn't write that song it
was spiritual
okay came out of kanye and wrote the gay
fish so okay
because he didn't even though he didn't
write he didn't write it but
but it was it was it was it was
spiritually written for him
you know you know what i mean he's a
genius a lot of people don't understand
that
he's a genius by by your interpretation
of that word you didn't understand that
no no he's a spiritual kanye west is a
spiritual
i'm sorry that he hurt you i'm sorry
that he hurt you
he didn't hurt me well that's what kanye
would say are you thinking i'm sorry
that i hurt you
no i like kind of i'm not hurt by that i
suck i saw kanye on [ __ ] um
joe rogan's show the new one and i'm
just and i've been watching kanye and
studying from afar
kanye west and he's an interesting man
he's a very interesting man
i like kanye i think he's very
good-hearted i do i just do
just i think he's a good man i'm
sorry y'all or something you don't
approve you know but well no but
yeller's so funny because i like him
they think that like
i like him uh all y'all people like
think that
y'all people where's all y'all young
people okay
all y'all people think that like people
that are on the left like me
yeah y'all think that like you're
hurting us
for some like being the way we just we
just think that it's like
kind of funny and like mildly mildly
amusing and like right here hurts you
we're like okay well you're like all the
you all like kanye is like okay he's a
[ __ ] but it's like it's like
that's not like hurting my feelings or
anything he's not a [ __ ] i don't even
like pay attention to him he's not a
[ __ ] he
he's a good guy i like him so he's got
his own
i don't know why you all think you're
like he's got his own team you don't
think you're
like owning the libs or something all
right the libs don't care
i ain't gonna talk about it i'm telling
you right now
i'm not gonna talk about it i don't care
i think he's good i saw i saw the
uh so i was watching joe rogan saw kanye
saw aj
so alex jones i like them both i'm just
saying it's
it it's an innovative [ __ ] thoughts
process it's a different way of looking
at things
and i'll just like them yeah if that's
the way you want to find it
it's [ __ ] funny it's innovative it's
very innovative it's funny and it's just
and and i think they're good it's an
innovative thought process
that's what i said that's what i said
it's an innovative thought process
and uh it's very it has a lot of
spiritual
qualities to it i like it okay that's
what i'm saying
it doesn't not everybody has to be the
same
not everybody has the same thing
[Laughter]
when kanye runs for president i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ]
vote for him i think he's gonna he'd be
the
the greatest president of all times the
first
african-american president i'm uh he's
not though
and i'm done with the stunt president's
just gotta
say it right now yeah no i think finally
an american president i think
i'm not sure barack obama was a
african-american president
i think he was too white kanye yeah but
you're that's you you're you're imposing
your own value system on someone
i can do that yeah i just like kanye
well you can but
but no one has to listen to you all
right that's it
okay all right you can do whatever you
want but no one has to listen to you
i just know he's okay i'm not gonna talk
we're just kind of like vaguely
mildly amused okay and
you know yeah [ __ ] it look man no one's
offended merry ham said
kanye is the picasso of our generation
did you know
that's exactly true exactly i think he
is
i don't know about that well picasso was
kind of a douche too
akasha was kind of a douche i mean
if you know anything about art history
okay he's kind of a douche
great artist but douche personally but a
lot of artists are
to be honest you kind of have to well i
don't want to say that like unreservedly
because
some artists are alright but i do feel
like to be like a great artist
yeah and i'm not putting kanye west in
that category this is getting a good
look man
tila's in there going well connie's the
first african-american president
we're in great trouble i got [ __ ]
photographs of me and kanye kissing
going way back
remember that remember that do i have to
photoshop that now
no we had that they i got that sent to
me
me and kanye was in [ __ ] did i make
that straight man love
no it was uh who made that uh [ __ ]
um who made that i don't remember a
photo friend of ours made a [ __ ]
photograph this i photoshopped a bunch
of [ __ ] without
five years old famous people about five
years but i remember doing a kanye west
i did you and david bowie i did you and
freddie mercury i did you and the
go-go's
i did you and evil knievel yeah yeah
yeah the evil knievel one was true
though but now that was that was uh
the evil knievel was good although i
will say that you and the go-go's that
was my best form yeah it was jim
dimitri dimitri made a photo oh and
demetri made it dimitri made a photo of
me and
that's right and kanye west west that's
right making out that was about five
now that was about that was a while back
six years ago i didn't even remember
something yeah because that was bad when
kanye was really
it goes to show how much i gave a [ __ ]
that was back when kanye was really
acting up
and i was acting up online
and at that around that yeah but just
trying to get attention
and and and and demetri made a photo of
me and kanye
he had it [ __ ] kind of photoshopped
it looked like we were making out
it was a [ __ ] awesome photo because
it it was good
when i first saw it i was like wait a
minute hold on when did that happen
and and then you i thought that might
have been something that happened
and i was like who is that black dude
that's the funniest part of it is that
you were just like
wait whoever who's that black did that
happen wait wait i like really drunk and
i just said
yeah yeah and jenny took a picture yeah
yeah
there's no talent i mean that could have
happened
because [ __ ] that's totally something
wild as
[ __ ] was six years ago something like
that could have happened i said jenny
who's that black dude you said this guy
came west and i said who
said do i know him he didn't even
know exciting who that was he was no no
no
and then i looked into it and i started
looking at the conway kanye west and i
[ __ ] said
that dude's looking hilarious i like
that guy he was [ __ ] funny
he's very spiritual and then he started
talking about out-of-body experiences
and seeing god and [ __ ]
recently i saw it and i was like yeah it
was
kind of like the near-death experience
that i had
you know what i mean so i'm just going
to say no
you might laugh at the dude but oh i
will
some of the [ __ ] he says checks out yeah
okay i ain't going to talk about it
you want these naysayers and [ __ ] but
[ __ ]
i think he's got a [ __ ] spiritual
element to him
i know i'm so terrible yeah yeah he
might know what he's talking about
um he checks out with checks out with
some of the stuff that i saw when i was
out of body
i don't know about [ __ ] all the
singing and everything of the [ __ ] of
a cosmic
singularity he called it god but i saw
it as a cosmic singularity
where everybody went after they died and
it was kind of like like i said
it was outside of the space-time
continuum there wasn't any past
or future there was only like a
universal present
and you could merge with that for a
while and experience something like
heaven until you reincarnated and came
back down into
[ __ ] physical form that you choose
these are all movies that we've chosen
to see
these lives we chose these lives but you
wouldn't understand that because you're
not one with the force like i
am say okay
you see me move objects with my [ __ ]
subconscious
i'm telling you man there's more to it
than what you're thinking jenny
we're not these physical beings we're
not these [ __ ] we're not this crude
matter
there's energy involved it's quantum
energy
it's consciousness victor says he has a
spiritual element to him because he
knows churches don't pay taxes
exactly exactly
ilsa says where is this conversation
gone
yeah tammy says i would never have
chosen this life right i didn't choose
this [ __ ] come on
some people want to see horror movies
and some people want to see romance
movies
and some people want to see action
movies you chose it
because there's other ones yeah but
here's the thing i feel like you're
going in a the secret direction which is
like an
open direction and i'm not willing to go
in the oprah direction
because the [ __ ] about the secret
is that it sounds good when you're like
oh well
you know you wish you like you only get
back from the universe like what you put
out into the universe so if you put out
like negative [ __ ] then you'll get
negative [ __ ] back
yeah well that's like blaming the victim
like so every time something bad happens
to you that means that you somehow
deserve it
and that's shitty so i'm like not
i'm not down with that because that's
the flip side of that that they never
really like
[ __ ] address nobody's saying annoys
me
no but i'm saying but that's the implied
other side of that [ __ ]
that's not how i look at it it is that's
not how i look at it
i don't believe that but i do believe
that people choose their own lives i had
that
[ __ ] i had kind of had that kind of
hit me
a couple times that you choose this [ __ ]
and it's just in the same way you would
choose to watch a movie
it's just that you're kind of like
you're getting too
hung up and the fact that some people's
lives suck well some movies suck
and just because your life sucks that
doesn't really mean anything you die
anyway we're all temporary
you'll have another life later it'll be
different that's just the way i look at
it that's that's
how it felt like to be nah but i'm just
hey
all right whatever whatever because
honestly like i feel like that
also you're also looking for justice in
life and there is no justice no but also
that kind of like lets you off the hook
because you're like oh well [ __ ] sucks
now but your life will be better next
time
it's like i kind of feel like it's
better to
in a way that's why i also i never
really got that
thing where because i'm an atheist and
like i always feel like people like got
on my
case because they're like well you don't
feel like life has any meaning or
anything i'm like on the contrary
i think life has actually more meaning
because this
is it this is all you get so you better
like make the [ __ ] most of what you
got
because you are not guaranteed like
anything like after you die so you
better like [ __ ] do
everything you want to do if you you
know just do all the good you can do
while you're here
because you don't get anything afterward
you don't get to like see anybody again
you don't
get to do anything so you have to
appreciate everything
now because that's all that you have you
don't get anything afterwards
so i feel like it's better to like
appreciate everything now then like wait
till some like later time it's like
oh we'll get them next life or it's like
oh i'll see them again later or
something because you might not
so get the [ __ ] that's your viewer do it
all now
that's what i'm saying yeah but that's i
i think that's a much like healthier
viewpoint honestly about it how much is
left on the
on the program do you have everything
done on that probably about it that's it
okay i mean go ahead and wrap it up i
don't really [ __ ] believe in um
what jenny's saying in terms of like
that's not how i see it
and i'm not looking for justice in it
um some people's lives suck you might
have a better one
later you might it might be worse even
but
uh it's all just part of the process and
it all works out
and that that's just that's just my
feelings on it yeah i mean but like i
said just feelings based upon what i've
seen in weird
out-of-body stuff it's also we're not
that important
you know what i mean we might vanish
eventually
but it's not time for that i i kind of
think that eventually what happens is
you start joining the [ __ ]
you eventually join like a spiritual
singularity where you don't have to do
this anymore
and that kind of like matches up with
what buddhists believe
is that ultimately what you're trying to
do is not being reincarnated
that way you don't have to live well
yeah the whole thing about buddhism is
that you have to like keep going through
like
until you like figure everything out
until you don't have to live and then
you don't have to like go through that
because they keep like if you do bad
[ __ ] they'll put you back in a [ __ ]
rat or something like that
yeah i didn't know that during the time
i was had those weird experiences but
looking back on it that would check out
that that would check that a perfect
state of being is non-existence
in that singularity not this thing where
you're you know what i mean that
life that life really is not good
you're trying to get out of it that's
really what
what it would mean well see that's the
thing i don't know if like i don't
i don't think those two things are
mutually exclusive though like
here's the thing like you can be like an
awesome person and make the best of your
life
while you're alive but that doesn't mean
that like after you die
it's like yeah like reincar i don't
believe in reality
i don't believe in ghosts or anything
like that but it's like i'm not averse
to the idea of like oh you got to keep
like repeating this [ __ ] until you
figure everything out yeah but you're
here and then you could be like here's
the thing
you're not the same awesome person
repeating it over and over again
you're only that awesome person for that
one life
you know what i mean after you die
you're no longer that person
you still have a certain point of view
but you live the life as another person
after that
is that pokey yeah jeez right there give
me a poke
there's a christian [ __ ] pre-concept
preconception that
a good soul goes to heaven and and that
you know you're an awesome person and
you're rewarded
that's not really well no i don't i
don't believe that
is that each one of each one of the
lives that you live you might be an
awesome person in one life and a shitty
person and the next and then a mediocre
one and the one after that
it's the same soul but it doesn't have
anything to do with what you're doing in
that life each one's a different movie
that you're watching
that's how i picked it up right and it
doesn't have anything to do with
being rewarded based upon that one
particular life that's just that one
life
well see that's the thing i don't expect
to be rewarded ever right
that's why i kind of feel like you just
have to take
like whatever life you have you just
have to find like
[ __ ] that has meaning for you or [ __ ]
that is like
that makes you happy in this life even
if it's like something small
you have to find that in this life
because you don't know if you're going
to get it
again yeah the way i remembered it was
is that each life had its own
particular thing you were trying to
experience everything
being a good guy a bad guy mediocre
person men or woman or whatever you're
trying to experience everything
but not within one lifetime in several
many lifetimes including the lifetimes
of animals and [ __ ] and possibly aliens
speaking of animals and then eventually
you've learned everything there is to
learn and you no longer have to live a
material life
then you join that singularity and you
disappear
but the singularity is outside of
spacetime
so it's difficult to know if you came
for the singularity or you're returning
to it
you know what i mean because it's
outside of spacetime
yeah i gotcha so it's difficult to know
what is past or present to that
but these are just things based upon
[ __ ] things that i saw in [ __ ] out
of body experiences
and some people would say well i could
have that if i take an ayahuasca and
[ __ ]
ask yeah it's subjective well i'd like
to take ayahuasca and compare the two
you know what i mean i'm i'm like
something out of down
what was that movie we saw altered
states i'm interested to know all of it
i don't really care that much are you
going to get her on the show no she's
right there what you doing come here
come here pokey i didn't even have any
video of you this time
yeah she's just kind of getting up she's
bathing in that blue i was going to make
you a witch hat and you wouldn't sit
still for it
i was going to say though this [ __ ]
douche that killed this whole family
william lisk jr he hanged himself yeah i
[ __ ] that dude
in 2015. yeah just thought i'd end it on
that like [ __ ] happy note so he's
dead
it's fine um you know i can't believe we
went like four
like what the [ __ ] were you even talking
about performing i don't know
shut it down let's go ahead and shut it
down got 57 you're not going to get
pokey on the show
no i can't grab her you can't keep it
okay she's back there i'm sorry
she just didn't want to come here pool
come here yeah she's coming
she's like what she's like thinking
about it she's like what are you gonna
do
come here come on come here sweet baby
she's like okay she's like reluctantly
poop there's pookie hey baby girl
she's like that
oh poor baby okay well thank you guys
for sh for uh sharing
halloween with us tonight yeah i can't
believe we only had one
trick go ahead and like share and
subscribe
yeah and we're always looking for new
patrons and uh
we will be back when well we're gonna do
another live stream of a movie tomorrow
tomorrow we'll be back tomorrow people
yeah and you know we always do a live
stream so it's sunday monday tuesday
wednesday
and we do record a shows and then we'll
do another show next saturday
and also if you're a patreon patreon
patron don't forget to go
and vote on the next topic and the next
movie retrospective you have until
tomorrow at noon eastern standard time
yeah to vote on the next topic and the
next movie that we do
okay thank you elsa and we will see you
guys tomorrow happy halloween
everybody hope you have a good rest of
your halloween thank you everybody
that dropped by thank you everybody that
contributed you guys are awesome
and uh we'll see you guys tomorrow
bye happy halloween